Democrat that's what we got out of our
hearing last week today we're here to
examine the impact of those actions on
the American people and launch into the
substance and human cost of secretary
Marcus's open border
policies as a result of the Reckless
actions by secretary morcus no American
is
safe there is a fentel epidemic sweeping
this nation roughly 150,000 Americans
died from fentel poisoning in 21 and 22
that's more than the number of us combat
deaths in World War I and the Vietnam
War
combined fenel is ripping apart our
families and destroying our communities
over 50% of this poison is being
smuggled from Mexico into Arizona before
it's dispersed throughout the United
States the Grand Canyon State is on the
front lines of this crisis which is why
we have um
had testimony by people who have related
the impacts on that state now you'll
hear many co of my colleagues on the
left claim that fentel is a ports of
Entry problem but in reality just last
year the border patrol intercepted
enough fenel between the ports of Entry
to kill every single American and that's
just what we've caught we have no idea
how much more fenel was brought in by
the nearly 1.8 million known Goda ways
not to mention the unknown godaa ways
border officials have told this
Committee in testimony that only 5 to
10% of the fentanyl coming across the
border is actually
seized by redirecting so many border
patrol Agents from patrolling the border
to assist with the processing and
release of illegal aliens secretary
moorus has made it far easier to smuggle
fentel across the Southwest border
because because of secretary marcus'
border crisis American cities and
neighborhoods are less
safe secretary meus is refusal to
enforce the law which requires him to
detain and remove illegal aliens has
tragically increased crime and
endangered Public Safety across the
country since fiscal year 2021 the
border patrol arrested more than 41,000
aliens with criminal convictions
including more than 15,000 in fiscal
year 23 that's up from just a little
over
4,200 in FY
2019 total convictions for assault
battery and domestic violence among
illegal aliens apprehended in FY 23
exceeded 1,00 compared to 299 in
fy9 these statistics do not reflect the
illegal aliens with criminal records who
have slipped through the system because
agents just don't have enough time or
information to vet them additionally DHS
has no way to determine if an alien has
a criminal history in his home country
unless that country reports the
information to the United States
government or the alien
self-reports therefore DHS is mainly
only screening aliens at the border to
determine if they have previously
committed a crime in the United States
and because many of these aliens are
coming to the United States for the
first time DHS has no idea whether they
have a criminal history or not on top of
rushing the vetting process secretary
Marcus is hamstringing ice making it
easier for illegal aliens who commit
crimes in the United States to stay here
despite his supposed pledge to focus on
removing threats to Public Safety ice is
arresting fewer criminal illegal aliens
than previous administrations in FY 2019
out of more than 143 administrative
arrests 86% were of criminal aliens in
fy20 during the covid-19 pandemic it was
90% last last physical year a mere
43% the consequences of this influx of
criminal aliens is simply
devastating again as a result no
American is safe illegal aliens arriving
in major cities like New York and
Chicago are committing assault theft and
even more heinous crimes in one case Dan
Daniel Hernandez Martinez who arrived in
New York in June 2023 has since
committed at least 14 crimes leading to
six arrests including the day after he
arrived in the in New York City in one
instance he quote grabbed a Stranger by
the hair dragged her across the floor
and kicked her end quote crimes stemming
from illegal migrants are also happening
in small towns Across America in May
2023 a Honduran National was charged
with raping a teenage girl in a
restaurant bathroom in prattsville
Alabama he had a prior criminal record
in Honduras when apprehended Crossing
into Texas illegally in November 21 but
he was released into the interior
anyway as we learned in last week's
hearing as many as 85% of illegal aliens
are currently being released on
secretary Marcus's watch the secretary
himself admitted this during a trip to
Eagle Pass just last week and how could
we forget the story of the tambunga
family Alyssa tambunga and her father
and sister who sat across from us in
this very hearing room Alyssa lost her
little seven-year-old Amelia and her
grandmother Maria in a car crash caused
by a human Smuggler with we will sadly
hear similar stories
today these crimes were wholly
preventable yet secretary Marcus's
policies enabled these criminals to
enter our country and Destroy these
families lives it's
despicable while many of my Democrat
colleagues likely feel the same sympathy
for you and your family that I do I'd
like to ask them to please turn that
sympathy into action it is hypocritical
to come up here offer your thoughts and
prayers and then leave continuing to
double down on the policies that allow
criminals and fentel into our country
the people suffering from this border
crisis don't need platitudes they need
an end to these illegal policies and to
see the man responsible for implementing
them held to account and that's what
Republicans are doing here
today migrants are also suffering as a
result of secretary marcus' actions on
secretary marcus' watch a record number
of migrants have been found dead on us
soil since the start of FY 2022 CBP no
longer longer even publicly reports the
number but Dr Karen Stern the medical
examiner in Webb County Texas said in
August 22 and I quote I'm seeing an
extreme increase in the number of border
crossing deaths compared to other years
this is my busiest year in my career
ever end quote many of those who
survived the journey have horror stories
as well sadly numerous migrants suffer
sexual abuse and assault along the way
then San Diego sector Chief Patrol agent
Aaron hiy told our committee in May and
I quote it's very common that female
migrants are raped during the process
most of them believe it's just part of
the payment as they go up end quote this
hearing is about the human CA of
secretary Marcus's egregious misconduct
and failure to fulfill his oath of
office the framers of our constitution
were clear that the executive branch
officials were expected to follow their
Duty and enforce the laws of this
country and if they willfully failed to
do so they should no longer hold office
that is why we're here today I look
forward to hearing from our Witnesses
and letting them tell their stories
about how this crisis has impacted them
unfortunately one of our Witnesses
Sheriff Daniels was not able to make it
at the last minute but we look forward
to hearing from him at a future hearing
or on a future border trip with his
permission I would ask unanimous consent
to submit his testimony for the record
without objection so ordered lastly I'd
like to point out that I have invited
secretary mayaras on multiple occasions
to testify on the border crisis
including this hearing today I'm
disappointed that he has chosen not to
testify instead he plays games and cat
and mouse telling the media he wants to
cooperate with the committee on finding
a time to testify but then refuses to
work with the committee staff or offer
any dates or times to which he can
testify despite this behavior and in lie
of his in-person testimony I have
invited him to submit testimony for the
record and I sincerely hope that takes
advantage of that
offer I'd like to ask unanimous consent
for my letters inviting secretary morcus
for Testimony dated August 16 September
14 January 5 and January 7th to be
entered into the record without
objection so ordered I now recognize the
ranking member the gentleman from
Mississippi Mr Thompson for his opening
statement thank you very much Mr
chairman good morning before we begin
today's hearing I want to address
misinformation my Republican colleagues
are spreading falsely alleging that
secretary mayorcas is refusing to
testify before this committee let me set
the record straight secretary me orcus
has testified before Congress more than
any other cabinet secretary he's
appeared before this committee twice in
the last year including just two months
ago when he testified for several hours
about Bo water security his willingness
to work with the committee has been a
welcome change from the Trump
Administration whose official
consistently refused to comply with
Congressional oversight they ignored
virtually every oversight letter and
even defied a subpoena for their
so-called acting secretary to appear
before the committee secretary me orcus
however has been forthright in dealing
with Congress in response to the
Chairman's request to testify at today's
hearing on January 11th 2024 the
secretary sent a letter agreeing to make
himself available to testify at a future
mutually agree on date however the
chairman has refused to accept instead
Republicans sent angry letters and
tweets accusing the Secretary of
refusing to testify knowing full well he
said he would appear Republicans are
acting in bad faith unfortunately that's
nothing new months ago chairman green
promised donor at a campaign event that
he'd bring an impeachment case against
Secretary of Homeland Security Alejandro
aorus he told his contributors to quote
get the popcorn and promised it's going
to be fun unquote before the committee
had even begun its inquiry Republicans
had predetermined
the
outcome but why did Republicans invite
the secretary to testify only to refuse
his offer to appear the answer to that
question appeared in the heel newspaper
last night Mr chair I act unanimous
consent to include in the record this
article from the heel describing how
Republicans had set the date for the
markup of Articles of impeachment before
holding the first hearing on this
subject as without objection so order
according to an internal Republican memo
dated January 10 2024 Republicans had
already scheduled a committeed vote to
impeach the secretary prior to holding a
single impeachment hearing just as we've
said all along the outcome of
Republicans so-called impeachment
investigation has been predetermined
from the start the chairman promised to
follow the facts but Republicans never
really intended to do so they hurrying
to adhere to an artificial timeline
agreed in a back room deal between
Republican leadership who's Holding On
by a thread and its most extreme Mega
members this isn't a real impeachment
it's a mega spectacle paid for by
American tax dollars for a republican
political gain but through it all
secretary Mayas remain committed to
doing his job the Department of Homeland
secur Mission and the men and women who
sered with him at DHS the secretary is
also committed to work diligently on a
bipartisan basis to secure necessary
funding for border security and to
prepare the department for a possible
shutdown I wish my Republican colleagues
would engage the secretary to provide
the department Department the funding it
needs but they've refused I look forward
to continuing to work with secretary
mayorcas on critical Homeland Security
issues facing the country and commend
him for his unwavering commitment to
duty even in the face of this sham
impeachment I also note for the record
that when I asked at last week's hearing
about providing a secretary due process
during the committee's impeachment
proceedings the chairman gave no
substantive answers to my repeated
inquiries in fact he seemed to have even
considered providing the secretary due
process and appeared unprepared to
respond this is unfortunate but not
surprising again this isn't a real
impeachment it's a predetermined
pre-planned partisan political stunt
yesterday the chairman threatened her
whole secretary mayor Us in contempt for
failing to appear before the committee
even though the secretary has already
agreed to appear That's not how contempt
works I can't help but wonder if
Republicans are getting a bit desperate
especially after their hearing last week
was a flop it fell flat after their
Witnesses three Republican politicians
rehashed old Paran talking points
without so much as a shred of evidence
to support their politically motivated
claims for
impeachment the Democratic witness
respected impeachment expert and
constitutional scholar professional
Professor Frank Bowman testify and I
quote policy differences no matter how
severe no matter how heed are simply not
grounds for impeachment
unquote you cannot impeach a cabinet
secretary because you you don't like a
president's policies that's not what
impeachment is for that's not what the
Constitution says unfortunately
Republicans are willing to damage the
Constitution they claim to hold dear
because they think it will benefit them
politically which brings us to today's
hearing I want to begin by expressing my
deepest sympathies to Mrs Noble and Mrs
Dunn on the tragic loss of your children
I cannot fathom your pain as a father
and a grandfather my heart truly goes
out to you indeed our hearts go out to
all those who' have lost loved ones to
drugs and violence and we are committed
to helping prevent future tragedies
Democrats want to strengthen border
security we want to keep fentol off our
streets we want to keep communities safe
we want to help those struggling with
with addiction but impeachment will not
do any of that the fact is impeachment
is a waste of precious time that could
be used to legislate on the Urgent
issues if only Republicans were willing
to do the Democratic witness
today Professor de Deborah pearlstein is
a constitutional law scholar but in
addition to her knowledge of impeachment
she's great expertise on the awesome
power vested in Congress by the
Constitution to affect change for the
American people that power is not
through impeachment as Professor
pearlstein stated in her testimony and I
quote impeachment of secretary mayorcas
can have no impact on the
administration's exercise of immigration
enforcement discretion a power the
Supreme Court has repeatedly recognized
is vested by the Constitution in the
executive branch unquote instead
congress power comes from its ability to
legislate as Professor pein goes on to
say quote no branch of government has
more power under our constitution to
address matters of border security than
Congress unquote in other words it's up
to Congress to provide funding to
interdict fentol fix our broken
immigration system and provide help for
those suffering from opioid addiction
that's our role in this to use the power
provided under the Constitution to
legislate on important issues to help
people who need it most are not some
baseless senseless impeachment I look
forward to hearing from Professor
pearlstein about congress's power to
make meaningful progress on these and
other
issues Mr chairman I made this plea to
you last week it fell on deaf ears but
I'll try again let's drop this baseless
impeachment and get back to doing the
real work of securing the Homeland and
helping people across this great country
uh before I yield back Mr chairman I
have a parliamentary inquiry I'd like to
you another chance at this
one you're recognized Mr chairman during
our hearing last week you said quote the
committee will follow the rules of the
house end quote
with regard to secretary mayorca due
process what provisions of house rule 11
grants the secretary representation
before this
committee
just a question of clarification on the
Parliamentary proceeding what rule are
you citing rule 11 rule 11 the secretary
is not appearing before the committee
today so his council is not
necessary Mr chairman we all know that
Secretary of mucus has been willing to
appear before this committee he's not
running from anything he's been to the
Capitol Hill 27 times since he was sworn
in
my question is about due process and
there's nothing in the standing house
rules that protects the secretary's
rights so Mr chairman pursuant to Clause
2j1 of rule 11 I'm Furnishing you with a
demand for a minority day hearing on
this subject signed by all the
Democratic members of this
committee
so the demand is not proper you have a
witness present
so uh before right yeah this is the
unanimous consent that include in the
record the article but also I have this
request for the uh you want this
included in the record is that what
you're asking well that's a request to
for a minority they
for the committee
okay so as I understand the rules the
request is only in order when you don't
have a witness present and today you
have a witness present so it this is not
in order Mr chairman may I make a
parliamentary inquiry on that yeah is
this an impeachment
inquiry you want to read the
request
um
yeah this this is actually a hearing not
an inquiry is this part of an
impeachment
investigation this is an impeachment
hearing okay under impeachment precedent
separate and apart from this particular
hearing the minority is allowed to have
a hearing of its own choice and its own
witnesses that has happened in every
single impeachment in history if this is
going to be an impeachment process then
there have to be rights and due process
afforded to the individual who is being
impeached and part of that historically
under historic precedent is that there
is a minority day with minority
determined Witnesses not a minority
witness who's added to a hearing that
the majority
determines so I want to make clear this
um supposed misinformation about uh the
request to secretary mayorcas there have
been
multiple multiple requests four in fact
of me to ask him to come and be a part
of this and he
has to the Press said yes to me not
provided any dates in some date in the
future you can't that's that's
stonewalling and and so at some point
after 4 I finally said I guess it was
Monday we just send is a testimony in
writing so far we haven't seen that
either the effort to give secretary
mayus an opportunity to come before the
committee in this context has been made
many times I appreciate that the ranking
member pointed out that he has been in
front of our committee but that was
mandated by you know the threats
briefing that's what he came for was the
threats briefing not a part of this
investigation on the Southwest border
every time we've invited him he has
refused to give us a date to come so
he's been afforded an opportunity to
come I understand that and that's a
separate
issue uh whether or not Mr myor has
wants to take part in his own
impeachment inquiry but the question for
you is that as part of the house
impeachment process there must be
afforded to the minority a hearing that
the minority gets to uh determine
because it's an impeachment process it
is not an a normal oversight
investigation what myor secretary my
orcus wants to do is a separate matter I
understand your your view and I
understand you know the ranking member
has has a different view um I'm sure we
will get all of the different letters in
the record and you know I have a article
here saying that the DHS letter
contradicts the GOP claim that my orcus
refused to testify which I could enter
by unanimous consent but we're just
talking right now about
the impeachment process and in this
committee where it has never been done
before it's normally in the Judiciary
Committee that there has to be a
minority day with minority determined
Witnesses I appreciate the letter um and
we'll take it into consideration and Mr
um uh ranking member you're recognized
for the remainder of your opening well
let me ask unanimous consent that that
be included in the record the without
objection so ordered so uh Mr chairman
rule 11 does not mention anything about
having a minority witness at any given
hearing it only provides for a minority
day I refer the chair to page
599 of the house rules
manual
were you asking a question Mr rank yes I
mean we didn't ask about a witness we
asked for a date yes I I I saw the
letter we've entered it into the record
and we want to continue with this
hearing we'll address that later no um
well Mr chairman this committee cannot
proceed uh to any markup I know you have
long that you have long plans in which
you committed to the speaker and to a
member of this committee uh behind
closed doors without a full hearing of
the merits of
impeachment but a minority Day on an
impeachment is allowed by the
rules thank you and so we're just trying
to no I appreciate you uh mention you
plan to honor that uh we'll take we're
going to take it into consideration and
I'll meet with you later to talk about
it well I do you have any do you have
any other comments for your remarks it's
a it's a simple uh request it's in the
rules and we just want the rules to be
followed there's an interpretation
disagreement on this um our
parliamentarian says that you're
entitled to Witnesses and not a specific
hearing we'll we'll take a look at it
after this and you and I can uh talk
about it then
Mr ranking member will you yield for a
question I just want to make sure
because I don't think it was entered
into the record before um the ranking
member referred to the letter that uh
council is or that council is secretary
my orcus send committee on January 11 if
I could M Mr
magaziner this is his opening statement
not not his 5 minutes he can yield time
to you in his five minutes okay I was
just going to ask unanimous consent that
the letter be entered into to the record
but I'm fine with that um we'll break
protocol here in just a second if
there's no objection so ordered Mr
ranking member you're recognized
still ranking member yields thank you
other members of the committee are
reminded that opening statements may be
submitted for the record I'm pleased to
have a distinguished panel of witnesses
before us today ask that our Witnesses
please rise and raise their right
hand
do you solemnly swear that the testimony
you will give before the committee on
homeland security of the United States
House of Representatives will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you
God let the record reflect that the
witnesses have answered in the
affirmative thank you you may be
seated I would now like to formally
introduce our Witnesses Miss Tammy nobl
Miss Nobles is the mother of a young
Maryland woman Kyla Hamilton who was
raped and murdered in July
2022 allegedly by a 17-year-old El
Salvador native an MS13 member who had
illegally crossed the Southwest border
in March 2022 as an unaccompanied alien
child Miss Dunn is an Arizona mother who
lost her 26-year-old daughter Ashley
done to fenel poisoning in 2021 since
her daughter's passing Josephine has
become an advocate working to stem The
Scourge that fentel is wreck Wrecking in
the United States Miss Deborah pearlson
pear
pearlstein um is the director of the
Princeton program in law and public
policy and Charles and Marie Robertson
visiting professor of Law and public
affairs before joining Princeton she was
professor of Law and co-director of the
flimer center for constitutional
democracy at Cardoza law school yashiv
University and held visiting
appointments at the University of
Pennsylvania Law School and Georgetown
University Law Center I thank all the
witnesses for being here today and I now
recognize Miss nobl for five minutes to
summarize her opening
statement good morning and thank you for
having me here today my name is tamy
Nobles I am the mother of Kayla Hamilton
July 24th 2002 was one of the best days
of my life I gave birth to a beautiful
baby girl and named her Kayla Marie she
loved to smile and laugh she always kept
her friends close and never forgot
anyone she was kind caring thoughtful
and funny she loved God she loved life
in God she showed the world that being
yourself was okay and you didn't have to
follow everyone else but sadly on July
27th 2022 I received the worst news that
a parent doesn't want to hear that my
newly 20-year-old daughter Kayla
Hamilton was murdered in her own room
and left on the floor like trash the
illegal MS 13 known gay member brutally
raped and murdered my daughter by
strangling her with a cord and robbed
her of
$6 during the attack Kayla called her
boyfriend for help but went to voicemail
the voicemail of the murderer strangling
Kayla was 2 minutes and 30 seconds long
DHS employees failed to visually inspect
the as salant by lifting his shirt to
check for Gang Related tattoos had DHS
employee employees performed a visual in
inection of the salent body they would
have seen MS13 Gang Related tattoos on
his body disqual disqualifying him from
entering the US DHS employees failed to
make a simple phone call to the El
Salvador government to verify if a
salent was on an MS13 gain affiliation
list had they done so El Salvador
government officials would have
confirmed that the salent was a known
MS13 game member with a prior criminal
history DHS supervisors have failed to
train and supervise DHS employees to
properly screen miners attempting to
enter us soil from El
Salvador the operational neglect
committed by DHS carried over into
DHHS whose operational neglect further
sealed my daughter's fate DHHS is
operational neglect included its
employees violating clearly articulated
protocol requiring a m minor to be
placed with a verified relative before
entering the US DHHS employees neglected
and recklessly failed to verify a
legitimate family member of the as
salant or sponsor before allowing him to
enter us soil there were clear
inconsistencies in the DHS and DHHS
records regarding the
identity of the relative to whom the
stellent was released
ultimately
dhs's hhs's failures to failures the
MS13 game member as a minor to rent a
room in a Trailer Park from another
individual who was also an illegal
immigrant there was also a lack of
transparency by DHS and DHHS including
but not limited to
DHHS failure to provide House of
Representative chairman Jim Jordan a
copy of its audit report
let's take a moment and think about how
Kayla felt that day how scared she must
have been that day knowing that she was
dying if she was going to see her mommy
again her baby sister her brother or her
cat
Oreo Kayla fought for her life that day
with all that she had and in the end she
lost to an individual that wasn't even
supposed to be allowed in the
country for me this is not a political
issue this is a safety issue for
everyone living in the United States
this could have been anyone's daughter I
don't want any other parent to live the
nightmare that I am living I am her
voice now and I'm going to fight with
everything I have to get her story told
and bring awareness of the issue at the
border if we had stricter border
policies my daughter would still be
alive today nothing will bring my
daughter back nor fix the pain of not
having her here but I want to prevent
this from happening to someone else
child this isn't about immigration this
is about protecting everyone in the
United
States
thank thank you Miss Noel uh I now
recognize Mrs Dunn for five minutes to
summarize her opening
statement good
morning before I begin I uh I wish to
thank you all for the gift of your
time I want to thank you for allowing me
to to share my beautiful daughter's
story as painful as it is for me to do
so I wish to spare as many parents the
unfathomable pain and debilitating grief
that I carry every single
day my daughter Ashley has left this
Earth
967 days ago today would have been her
29th
birthday in the next five minutes you
will see many beautiful photos of Ashley
on the
screens photos are all that my family
and I have left of
her that's not true I guess we do have a
small amount of ashes in an nurn and we
do have our memories in that same five
minutes that I get to share her story
after I traveled all the way from
Arizona for Mr mayorcas not to appear
here
today someone else's loved one in the
United States
stage will die in this same five minutes
that I get to
speak because of fenel over the next 24
hours
190 loved ones in this country will die
from fenel 50% of that fenel is coming
through my state with an open
border the beautiful state of Arizona
today will lose five people to fenel
five you see
Arizona
recognizes that fenel is a weapon of
mass
destruction while you see her beautiful
smile and almond shaped eyes scroll
across those screens more often than not
I remember her
differently every time I close my eyes I
see all of the
tubes when it's quiet I hear all the
machines that were keeping her alive you
see my husband and I had to sit for 86
hours in the
ICU while we were begging God because
yes we're Christians and we're
conservative we're from Arizona we were
begging God we were pleading God
bargaining that she would just
breathe over the last 32 months Ashley
did not celebrate her son's fifth sixth
or seventh birthday day she did not
watch her baby graduate from
kindergarten she did not celebrate
Christmas or Thanksgiving nor did we as
a family I'm sure you guys
did so she celebrated the last of her
birthdays when she was 26 she will
forever be
before you decide how you feel about my
family and about fentel understand that
pensional affects all walks of
life by the time my testimony is over
please
know that one person will have died
Ashley had brown hair and the most
beautiful eyes Ashley with one smile
would steal your heart Ashley had a kind
heart and a gentle
soul I understand that the mission of
the Department of Homeland Security is
to secure our nation's air Land and Sea
borders to prevent illegal activity
while facilitating lawful travel and
trade in my humble opinion Mr mayor's
border
policies is partially responsible for my
daughter
death his wide open border policy allows
massive quantities of poisonous fenel
into our
country Arizona is the fenel
superhighway into the United
States I personally feel Mr mayorcas is
responsible for opening that border to
allow more than 10 million illegal
border crossings since February of
2021 which supports most of the illegal
Sentinel into this
country this weapon of mass destruction
has killed over 100,000 Americans on our
soil for 2 years in a
row under secretary May oris's
leadership or lack thereof fenel is in
Invasion the weapon of mass destruction
has caused
unimaginable numbers of deaths
unmeasurable damage to our country's
family families including my
own my family is
broken my heart is broken and he
couldn't even be here to face me
today whatever he's doing that is more
important than facing me
today I don't know what that could be
our country deserves a secure border our
country deserves to feel safe our
country deserves to be free of
fantinel we need to close the fentel
Super Highway we need to close the
border thank
you thank you Miss D I now recognize
Miss pearlstein for five minutes to
summarize her opening
statement
thank you very much chairman green
ranking member Thompson members of the
committee thank you for the invitation
to participate in the committee's
consideration of whether constitutional
grounds exist to impeach Department of
Homeland Security secretary my orcus I'm
been a professor of constitutional law
for more than a decade a director of two
different academic centers focused on
the study of constitutional
democracy I've studied written and
taught about the unique role impeachment
plays in our system of
government as a mother and a former
human rights lawyer I couldn't take the
subject matter in front of the committee
today more
seriously my expertise however is in the
field of constitutional law not an
immigration policy as such and my
testimony solely in my personal capacity
is thus limited to questions of
constitutional Authority that are
relevant here while my written statement
goes into greater detail in these few
minutes I'd like to highlight just two
points first impeachment is a narrow
remedy for a specific kind of misconduct
limited by the Constitution to address
addressing offenses against our system
of government that cannot be solved
through ordinary channels of
redress second no branch of government
has more power under our constitution to
address matters of border security than
Congress although the framers of the US
Constitution were convinced that
impeachment would have to be retained
from the British regime they had just
overthrown as a remedy against the most
egregious offenses of public officers
they were determined to limit the scope
of the power to ensure it remained
consistent with the new design of our
constitutional democr democracy Central
to our system is this principle of
separation of powers each branch of
government remains independent with none
empowered to fully control the members
of the others because impeachment was a
potentially dangerous exception to that
overriding principle the framers
significantly narrowed the scope of the
impeachment power is it existed under
the law of the king above all the
framers significantly narrowed the
grounds for which officials could be
impeached and is now treas and bribery
were recognized as the most serious
offenses against a system of government
in which the American people were asked
to entrust elected leaders uh with
acting in their interest treason was a
betrayal of the interests of the
American people in the in favor of the
interests of a foreign enemy bribery
involved a public official placing his
own interests in personal power
enrichment above the interests of the
public by lame by labeling the other
category other high crimes and
misdemeanors the framer signal that they
meant to include only those offenses
that posed a similar L severe threat not
to a particular area of public policy
but to the very system of government
that depends on officials acting in good
faith on behalf of the people who place
them in office policy differences could
be addressed through elections
impeachment was to be and largely has
been a last ditch mechanism to address
offenses against constitutional
democracy by a single individual that
can't be adequately addressed through
ordinary channels of
government second point the first and
most important remedy the Constitution
provides to address perceived failings
of the president and the executive
branch Remains the separation of powers
including congress's authority to affect
policy change itself when it comes to
immigration in particular the Supreme
Court has long described congressional
power in the field as plenary article
one of the Constitution grants Congress
the power to set the terms and
conditions by which a foreign National
may become a US citizen sweeping
authorities to provide for the common
defense and general welfare of the
United States
the power to make all laws necessary and
proper for carrying out these duties and
Article 1 Section 9 gives Congress the
exclusive power over how the US
government allocates its
resources these vast Powers which the
Constitution sets out in its very first
article remain among our democracy's
most fundamental checks on the exercise
of executive
power despite these vast reserves of
constitutional Authority a spike in
partisan polarization in recent decades
a refusal to work across cross partisan
lines to solve common problems has meant
the power to address pressing National
problems has gone
unused nowhere has this effect been more
apparent than in congress's Failure to
develop national policy on immigration
despite all that has changed the last
significant piece of comprehensive
immigration legislation to pass congress
with bipartisan support was in
1986 the action under consideration here
impeachment isn't a tool of policy
change
particularly the impeachment of a single
cabinet official who can be replaced by
another official given precisely the
same role will have no effect on the
heartbreaking problems we have heard
described without taking a position on
the wisdom of any particular bill now
under consideration I understand that
multiple pieces of bipartisan
legislation are today pending in the
house very active negotiations underway
in the Senate the framers of the
Constitution well understood the acute
difficulty of embracing compromise with
their domestic political opponents but
for the purpose of actually addressing
the needs and easing the pain of the
people who live in this country the
framers of the Constitution thought that
no one in government could do more to
make a real difference than
you thank
you thank you Miss pin members will be
recognized by order of seniority for
their five minutes of questioning an
additional round of questioning may be
called after all members have been
recognized I now recognize myself for
five minutes of
questioning
Miss pearlstein uh in 2019 on a New York
Public Radio podcast you were asked what
you took away from a congressional
hearing on impeachment standards your
response was as
follows ask so this is an exchange that
came out of and really belonged in the
panel in which the Constitutional law
professors were appearing um and there
the professors were reasonably uniform
right in recognizing in that it doesn't
have to be a crime that is to say an
impeachable offense doesn't have to be a
crime as currently embodied in the
federal criminal code um as enacted by
Congress the existing criminal laws
didn't exist when the framers wrote the
Constitution and indeed crimes as such
weren't what the framers had in mind
when they put impeachment into the
Constitution what they were thinking
about with the impeachment remedy were
serious offenses uh against the public
trust that is certain things that only
the president and other senior officials
could do that abused their Authority in
other words the idea of abuse of power
is sort of
the do you still stand by those words
yes just a yes or no quick question it
is absolutely the case the Congress
doesn't have to show a violation of
Title 18 of the US code it has to show
that there was a high crime or
misdemeanor reclaiming my time um I
think your the words that are very
interesting to me is a serious offenses
against the public trust Miss Nobles
Miss stun do you think that our open
border policies which have allowed fenel
to pour into this country a million
point8 Goda ways unknown Goda
ways is an offense against the public
Trust of this
country yes
definely Mr
stun
yes Miss Nobles the committee has been
focused well first before I ask your
question I I one of the things that was
very interesting in your opening
statement Mr pin was about the power of
Separation the separation of
powers and you and you talk about
Congress having the remedy to make laws
to fix the immigration issue and the
Border issue but see we passed a law
that says shall detain
Mr mayorcas has in has sub has basically
completely reversed that so we could
you're right we could pass more laws in
fact we tried we passed hr2 but it won't
pass the H Senate because they refuse to
take it up but yes we have the power to
pass more laws they're not even
following the laws that are already
written and that from my standpoint
is basically a refusal to understand the
separation of powers that we write the
laws and they enforce them but the
secretary doesn't seem to care about
that nor does he seem to care about the
four court orders which have told him
he's doing that and said cease and
desist with these policies that are
absolutely subverting the law and he
refused to follow those court orders
Miss Nobles the committee has been
focused on the Biden administration's
refusal to secure our Southwest border
and vet alien arrivals a report from the
house Judiciary Committee pointed out
multiple vetting failures with your
daughter's
killer its report shows that your
daughter's murderer was arrested for
association with the MS13 well before he
came to the United States something the
United States officials
verif verified easily after the murder
occurred the report also noted that the
alien was released after he was arrested
for murder do you think that secretary
me Arcus has done an adequate job of
vetting illegal aliens coming across our
Southern border no
and mayass say that it took the local
detectives to find out that he was an
MS13 gang
member um Homeland Security and in
Department of Health and H service did
not know that until after he killed my
daughter and then they try to write it
in there after the fact but it was
already let out that they failed to know
that he was in 13 game member Miss D do
you believe secretary mayorcas genuinely
cares about the well-being and SA safety
of US citizens like your daughter
considering that his actions are
directly responsible for aggravating and
fueling the ongoing fentel crisis
absolutely
not thank you I yield I now recognize
the ranking member for his five minutes
of questioning thank you very much uh
let me say from the outset every
opportunity to provide resources for the
Department of Homeland Security
Democrats on this committee have always
given them what they've asked uh the
majority of Republicans on this
committee they've not given them
resources so we interview
people in the department the number one
issue that comes up is we need more
resources technology sometime Manpower
sometime just the ability to inct and
that is what we've tried to provide on a
regular basis and I encourage my
colleagues that when the next
opportunity come to fund the department
let's listen to the men and women who
work in the department who say they need
the resources and let's give it to
them uh Professor pearlstein last week
you joined two dozen of the country's
most knowledgeable constitutional
lawyers on a bipartisan letter to
speaker Johnson and chairman green
explaining that the Republican case
against secretary mayorcas
is unjustified as a matter of
constitutional law can you explain in
simple terms why you and your colleagues
concluded that impeaching the secretary
is unjustified under the
Constitution thank you Mr ranking member
yes um the term High crimes and
misdemeanors which is what's an issue
here is a limited term of art it
includes only those offenses against the
system of government not ordinary crimes
offenses against the structure of
government comparable to treason and
bribery offenses that interfere in the
way the government works the allegations
that have been set forth here uh which
are very serious are profound complaints
about the policies that the current
Secretary has pursued their policies
that the secretary has pursued under the
current president of the United States
who appointed the secretary and was
elected to pursue those policies policy
differences and I agree with my
colleague at the last hearing no matter
how profound are exactly not what
impeachment was meant to be for the
framers were very worried that
impeachment would become something like
a tool of the parliamentary system so
that Congress could in essence hold the
president and the president's
Administration on a leash the framers
wanted each branch to remain independent
to make their own policy judgments so
that their ambition could counteract
ambition and they would fight each other
on Democratic terms over what the right
answer was thank you very much uh I also
want to talk to you about uh how
Republicans and Democrats on this
committee can work together to
strengthen B border security and address
the opioid crisis Democrats agree about
the need for Action to help families
like those on our panel today and
prevent further
tragedies uh professor in your testimony
you say and I quote the first and most
important remedy the Constitution
provide to address perceived failings of
the president and executive branch
Remains the separation of powers
including congress's constitutional
authority to affect policy change itself
in other words if the Congress Cong
doesn't like what an Administration is
doing the Constitution gives its power
to pass laws to direct a different
course of
action can you explain the power
Congress has under the Constitution to
expect
change thank you Congress has uh the
most power of any branch in the
government to affect change it has under
article one the exclusive power to spend
any money and allocate resources on
behalf of the United States uh it also
has the other powers that I listed in my
opening remarks um and critically while
it does have the power to pass laws
sweeping laws uh and has it is also
subject to the rule of the Supreme Court
which has in the allegations that issue
here twice rejected the arguments that
were noted by the chairman moments ago
uh that in fact there was a violation of
law here those laws remain on the books
uh and Congress can do additional things
principally through funding but not
exclusively to make them even
stronger thank you I yield
back the gentleman Yi I now recognize
the chairman of the committee on Foreign
Affairs house committee on Foreign
Affairs um the gentleman from Texas Mr
McCall thank you Mr chairman thank for
holding this uh powerful hearing I was a
federal prosecutor I was Deputy attorney
general for the State of Texas for
criminal justice I worked with the
victims of crime that's what we do and
we talk a lot about facts and figures
about the Border you know
statistics but your stories are the most
powerful because the real life stories
about the impact of this man's violation
of the public
trust and and I do I just I I agree with
your
podcast that it doesn't have to be a
federal statute because they didn't have
a lot of federal statutes from the
founding fathers were at the
Constitutional Convention in fact the
Supreme Court recently held that
impeachment is a tool Congress can use
to hold this secretary accountable it's
the legal
justification I believe he's violated
his oath he's violated the public trust
he's violated your
daughters
I intend to personally uphold my o to my
country that I took in office it's been
a d elction of Duty of the grossest
proportions I've seen in my 25 years of
dealing with this
border Miss D I um I couldn't agree with
fitel is a weapon of mass destruction I
passed a bill out of my committee
defining it as such it comes from China
and they make it in Mexico and they kill
our children here
200,000 more than Vietnam World War
II my children have been to six funerals
now I've seen it personally the
destruction it does every five minutes
it is a fentel super highway and this
border policy is personally responsible
for it he took a oath to
defend and protect the Constitution and
the American people air Land and Sea
from enemies foreign and domestic Miss D
do you believe he violated that
oath yes sir I flew from
Arizona to meet him and face him and ask
him why and he's not here today I did
not know that until after I landed
yesterday and he doesn't have the
decency no to even show up that is
correct and talk to you personally today
is my daugh daughter's birthday I would
have much rather been home with my poor
husband grieving her I didn't need to be
here today so whatever he's doing I hope
it's more important than that let me say
I'm sorry thank you because apparently
the secretary doesn't care to show up
and say that to you no do you know he's
meeting with Mexican officials today
exactly how does that make you feel oh
you have no idea how I feel I'll be
meeting with Mexican officials later
next week and I'm going to have a
different story for them I'm going to
have your storyk that I will take to
them Miss
nobl God you know these these gang
bangers come in and they join
trafficking organizations are being sent
to families that don't exist because
it's a Trafficking Organization in the
United States this man this one man who
deserves impeachment has created a
criminal inter prize in the United
States of America 8 million encounters
what are we going to do with all these
millions of people with no legal status
who can't get a real job so what do they
do it's drugs gang banging
murder I've seen it in my career and
they're the worst and it sickens me what
happened to your daughter and you must
relive it in your head every single day
what she went through what your poor
daughter had to experience that day do
you hold Mr my orcus personally
accountable for the death of your
daughter yes I do I do too and that's
why he needs to be impeached do you hold
him personally accountable for what he
did you hold him personally accountable
for the policies he established which
violated the public trust and ended up
in the death of your
daughter
yes and yet doesn't have the decency or
the guts to show up to you today and say
I'm sorry did
he no he did
not I mean she was killed three days
after her 20th birthday she spent three
days being 20 and I sent her a message
on her birthday on July 24th that I was
proud of the woman that she was
becoming and that I love her and I
didn't know that would be my last
message of telling her that I love her
she even bought herself I even got gave
her the money to buy her a um JoJo sua
cake because that is who she loved and
she had autism and she loved
Jojo and her life was brutally taken and
she had no idea what to expect that day
when she went to bed after getting off
the night shift of work and went to
sleep in her own bed and had no idea
what was going to happen on July 27th
let me just close by saying I have a
daughter that is your daughter's age she
has a cat named Snickers I know your
daughter had a cat named
Oreo um this is the personal side of
this chaos created by this man this is a
personal life story of the cause and
effect that has happened because of
these failed policies On the Border it's
destruction and it's death and it has to
stop with that I Y back the gentleman
yields I now recognize uh the gentle
lady from uh Texas Miss Jackson Lee for
her five minutes of test of
questioning as a mother I would like to
begin by offering my sincere condolences
uh to miss dun and Miss
Nobles for the devastating losses that
they and their families have experienced
no amount of sympathy and thank yous can
compensate for the
loss no one should ever have to
experience the loss of a
child so please know that we are
committed to making our community safer
and combating the
heinousness of drug trafficking and
other violence that
comes for those that should not be in
this country um and should not take
advantage of the innocent people who are
here which includes your
children Mr chairman the stories of Miss
dun and
Nobles are
gut-wrenching they are
clearly for any of us we cannot stand in
their shoes no matter how much we try to
empathize try to seem like we are
standing in their shoes trying to use
language that would create hysteria to
seem like we have the same pain
nobody no
one can express the pain that a parent
that is lost a child can feel it is
gut-wrenching but you brought them
here
unfortunately where our Solutions may
not be the solutions that they seek
under the false pretense that impeaching
secretary mycus would be in any way
prevent what happened to their children
from happening to someone
else's it wouldn't and I think you know
that
what is worse is that the Republicans on
this committee are not leveling with
Americans about the actions that they
have taken or not taken to secure the
border and combat drug trafficking the
truth is at every opportunity
Republicans at the federal and state
level have pursued policies politics
over policy and obstructed efforts to
improve conditions at the border we need
more resources we need more skilled
personnel we need more ways to keep bad
guys out of here to ensure the
protection of the
innocent precious children of these two
mothers in Washington all but nine of my
Republican colleagues voted against the
FY 2023 Omnibus which provided much
needed increases on cson border of
protection funding to increase Personnel
along the border and improve fetell
detection Republicans have refused to
act on the president's supplement
request sitting right here waiting for
us to act which would
provide additional resources not only
for CBP but also for communities
receiving migrants and instead of
considering politics policies to improve
security along the border or prevent
drug trafficking and treat fenol
addiction we are willing or sitting here
today at a feudal impeachment proceeding
we need to give hope to these parents
we need to give love that shows
action so let me quickly ask Professor
pearlstein Republicans have argued that
the secretary should be impeached for
failing to secure the Border yet most of
them have voted against funding for
border security that the administration
requested if Republicans really wanted
to secure the
border is it more effective to provide
the funding that the Administration has
requested or to impeach the
secretary let me add this question as
well uh if you can incorporate both of
these as I noted the governor of Texas
has blocked border patrol from entering
areas along the US Mexico border if
Republicans really wanted border patrol
to improve enforcement along the
Southwest border does it make sense to
exclude border patrol from areas
surrounding the Border in fact we lost a
mother and two children just recently do
you believe a state can do that under
the
Constitution thank you doctor this
question is is for you thank you
representative Jackson Lee uh I can't
speak to policy Effectiveness it is
certainly within congress's power today
in the Republican side as well as the
Democratic side to vote Appropriations
that would actually support programs for
fental addiction and programs that would
support families who've lost loved ones
to uh to any of these um I can't speak
to the details of what's happening on
the border today but the general rule of
the Constitution is federal law under
the Constitution is the supreme law of
the land uh State efforts to interfere
with Federal efforts to ENT to enforce
border laws are
unconstitutional let me just quickly say
Mr chairman this impeachment proceeding
um is not going where we want it to go
we want to help these parents we want to
cry out for them but we want to give
them Solutions we want to focus on a
border security Mission with the
resources that Congress has afforded
department and within the confines of
the law my Republican colleagues would
rather deprive DHS of the reasonableness
and resources it needs to carry out its
border security Mission so that it can
attack the secretary who himself I've
seen show great remorse for the losses
of
individuals impeaching him is that the
answer to saving our children I would
hope that we would come together Stand
Together to be outraged over the loss of
anyone's precious precious child and
Stand United as the American people to
fight against this dly act of drugs and
viciousness at the border and make our
borders safe for Americans and as well
as those who come to this country for
the right reasons all of them are our
neighbors who live in the southern uh
part of the United States they are our
neighbors and we should try to find a
way but we should not ignore the pain of
these parents parents we can do both and
we do not have to make a mockery of
impeachment we can work with the
Department of Homeland Security and our
Secretary of Homeland Security and this
president who cares with that Mr uh
chairman I Yi the Gent lady yield I now
recognize Mr Higgins for his five
minutes of
question thank you Mr
chairman Mr
chairman our Southern border
under the control of secretary May
orcus is
1,954 miles of
failure 10 million illegal Crossings in
three years the
disintegration of American sovereignty
total loss of American Law and
Order exponential enhancement of cartel
human trafficking operations and cartel
narcotics trafficking millions of
American families crushed by Financial
loss and the Unspeakable
grief of unprecedented loss of American
lives to drugs and violent crime this is
the legacy of secretary Alejandro
mayorcas and as God is my witness we
will impeach that man in this
committee we will hold him
accountable for his colossal failure
and we will take no pleasure in doing
so because it closes the the the chapter
of a disastrous era of American
History we've largely lost our country
down
there this body should be discussing
sending massive military aid to Texas
not to
Ukraine
Miss Nobles M
dun I lost a daughter long
ago it's a club nobody wants to
join and I
listened was difficult to
listen to your testimony and I read your
submitted
testimony
and the message that I
received is that your
daughters are
perfected and they are very very proud
of you
both I promise
you we will
hold secretary mayoras
accountable and further the administ
ation that he
serves Miss
Nobles I'm going to ask you to reflect
upon a particular
policy at
our at the Biden
Administration and secretary May orcus
pursues the Department of Homeland
Security and the Department of Health
and Human Services have systems in
place to quote unquote ensure that
unaccompanied Ali children from
non-contiguous countries are transferred
from Customs and Border Protection to
the office of refugee resettlement o r
r with the house Judiciary
report regarding your daughter's
murder notes that the office of refugee
resettlement o
RR had lost track of more than 85,000
children and placs fewer than than
15,000 follow-up calls calls not
personal visits after discharging an
additional 32,000 children now at no
point did
anyone under secretary May oris's
command flagged the the violent
criminal that murdered your
daughter no at a criminal gang history
along with multiple MS13 tattoos
new what would your daughter
say about a secretary Department of
Homeland Security who facilitates A
system that has lost over 100,000
children mostly young teenage
girls Mrs
no sorry what was your question what
would your daughter say about oh over
100,000 lost
teenage children of
God system run like that she would be
very I'm sure she' be very
upset a heart would break for those
children would they not
yes Americans just like her require
action that's what this committee will
deliver Mr chairman my time has expired
gentleman's time has expired the
gentleman from California Mr Korea is
recognized for 5 minutes thank you Mr
chairman and first of all let me uh
thank our Witnesses for being here today
Miss D Miss Nobles I'm also a father
like many of us here represent an area a
lot of hardworking Americans surviving
dayto day my four kids were growing up
we invested a lot of time and effort
Little League little league basketball
keeping them away from that bad
stuff
remember
story my fellow father another father in
Little League his kid was a gifted
athlete he was going to be the next
major league player his dad was there
every day pitching to him bucket after
bucket of
baseballs then one day they stopped
showing
up later on I found out that that young
man man and his dad started going to
drug
rehab that son had come under the spill
of hard drugs and I've never seen them
again stories like yours I wish I could
say we're
not we're uncommon in my district but
I've heard them way too many times each
one that I hear your story is a pain and
suffering in my district we live through
heroin addicts that Co Caine surge crack
PCP and now fentanyl the worst of
all this is the reason why all of us
here the federal level Democrats
Republicans on both houses with a
president have to stop biggering have to
stop fighting come together to protect
Middle America in this country
man when it comes to fentel
you said Arizona
50% I'll tell you I've been to the
Border I've talked to our CBP officers
they tell me
65% of all the fento crosses through the
sedra Port of Entry just one port it
goes
north through my county and that's why
we have so many problems in our area you
have one set of numbers CBP has another
set of numbers but it is a challenge
that we have to
address
CBP in 2019 we had 20 seizure of 2800
lbs 2019 we had over
27,000 pound of CBP Seas 800% increase
but based on those border officers this
is about 10% of what's coming through
they he's about 10% 90% probably still
gets through and I've asked those border
officers what do you need to do your job
better you know what they've told me we
need more resources we need more
Personnel when those officers tell me
I'm working 16-hour
shifts we need more Personnel we have to
respond with more resources it's not Lou
it's the men and women at the border
telling us what they need
so Professor
pin der elction of Duty is not an
impeachable offense
correct the amount of correct the amount
of seizures at the border I would say
shows that somebody's doing their job
there it's just a
lot what's better for us to do fight
over an impeachment or respond to
president's Biden ask for additional
resources at the Border in your
opinion impeachment will have no impact
on resources available to the Border it
will have no impact on the policies
pursued by this administration at all
funding change the appropriation of
money for additional officers for
example to um improve fentel seizure
oper operations
uh based on what you've described
certainly might have any effect and
indeed maybe a good effect impeachment
has none and I've
just asked my colleagues here today
let's get it together surge resources to
the Border make sure we stop fentel from
Crossing into our
country every day that we debate over
funding level
is another day that more Americans die
from fenel the chairman thank you and I
yield the gentleman yields gentleman
from Mississippi Mr guest is recognized
for five minutes uh thank you uh Mr
chairman uh I want to rebut a little bit
the argument that's been made by my
colleagues on the other side that
Republicans aren't willing to secure
resources for the border and I'll just
tell you that that is a complete
absolute misstatement of fact incept
September the House of Representatives
passed an Appropriations package for the
Department of Homeland Security that
appropriate an additional $2
billion those funds would go to hire
additional agents those funds would go
to Merit pay those funds would go to
invest an additional technology to stop
the flow of fanel coming into this
country we also passed hr2 which would
have done the exact same thing and so
for my colleagues on the other aisle to
say we should be more focused on funding
DH s and what we're doing here today I
would argue that we have done that we
passed our Appropriations Bill we sent
it to the Senate and Chuck Schumer has
let that bill sit there Gathering dust
refusing to bring either hr2 or the
House Appropriations Bill to the senate
for a vote and so for them to say that
is a complete and utter
misstatement of the
facts um Professor pearling uh I do
agree with you uh in your statement uh
where you said that we do not have to
have a violation of the federal criminal
code for impeachment and agree with you
when you say serious offenses against
public trust would arise to the level of
impeachement uh prior to being elected
to congress I served as a prosecutor in
my local community uh tried many jury
trials I remember often hearing the
judges tell potential jurors that
reasonable good minded people can reach
different
conclusions when applying facts to the
law the law in this case I believe is
the Constitution the impeachment Clause
uh that we as reasonable members of
Congress must apply the facts and the
facts as I view them and they may be
different than viewed by other members
of Congress everyone views those uh and
using their own perspective uh I believe
that there is is ample evidence I
believe that secretary mayor is violated
his oath to protect and defend the
Constitution I believe that secretary
mayorcas has willfully failed to enforce
the law particularly the Ina where it
says repeatedly that the secretary shall
detain and remove immigrants I believe
that secretary May orcus has lied to
Congress when he has repeatedly come in
and said that the border is secure I'll
tell you an example just last year in
April of last year as secretary mayorcas
came and he sat there where you were
sitting Miss dy I had the opportunity to
ask him are all nine sectors of the
Southwest border secure and his answer
was yes now his answer contradicted the
answer given just three weeks prior by
his chief of border patrol Chief Ortiz
when Chief Ortiz said five of the nine
sectors on the Southwest border are not
secure so I believe he's violated his
oath to protect and defend the
Constitution I believe that he has
willfully failed to enforce law and I
believe that he has lied to Congress now
Professor I see in your statement that
you provided you say that really only on
two occasions back in 1904 and8 excuse
me 1804 and 1872 where you had the
removal of two US District Jud judges uh
where they were removed one because one
was chronically inebriated and the other
was mentally
incapacitated uh and you said that they
were unable to carry out their duties
because of that I believe that a person
who
willfully chooses not to carry out their
duties is more impeachable than someone
who has some sort of meal mental
inability to do so and I believe that
the record is clear if you look at what
this committee has done to show that
secretary May orcus has refused to carry
those duties
out now I want to ask you because you
clearly say in your report Professor uh
that you've given that Congress uh that
there appears to be no constitutional
basis for um pursuing this
impeachment uh my question is relating
to a different impeachment matter did
you feel that way last Congress for the
two impeachments of President Trump did
you feel that there was a constitutional
basis for the impeachment of Donald
Trump either his first or second
impeachment I did okay and so this
matter differs in Secretary mayorcas
from both the first and second
impeachment of the former president yes
and in what Manner several uh first
although I've heard now several times
the allegation here that secretary
mayorcas was in some respect violating
his legal responsibility those claims
the specific claims you've raised about
detention enforcement power were ra
raised and litigated all the way up to
the Supreme Court by the state of Texas
M let me ask can reasonable people can
reasonable people can reasonable people
look at the facts and draw different
conclusions reasonable people can't draw
different conclusions about the law as
apply you have to apply the law to the
facts I understand and I don't believe
that there is sensus that your version
of what you believe the law is uh is
actually I I yield back thank you
gentleman from Texas M Jackson Lee is
recognized for the purpose of entering
something into the record I thank you Mr
chairman i' I ask unanimous consent to
submit into the record um a article why
America is struggling to stop the finol
epidemic uh and uh an
article uh that says how final crisis
fourth wave has hit every corner of the
United States ask youan to place those
in the record without objection so order
thank you the gentleman from Louisiana
Mr Carter is recognized Mr chairman
thank you very much before I begin I
want to First personally thank uh these
Brave Witnesses for being here a heart
goes out to you and your families for
your incredible loss um we all recognize
the significance and the importance of
this this matter uh it's been brought to
my attention that our chairman as we
speak is in the hallway doing an
interview with Fox News instead of
listening to the testimony of these uh
heartbroken parents I think that
demonstrates just where we should be we
should be here not talking to Talking
Heads and feeding into that um you know
my colleagues was the past year blaming
secretary Mar Arcus for long-standing
issues like immigration drug addiction
crime and so forth however impeachment
over differences in policy is not
constitutional it also solves exactly
nothing for the problems that we were
sent here to Congress to
solve
it's high time that we as members of
Congress must come together to pass laws
that combat fentanyl in our communities
and fund drug treatment programs to help
save lives not to determine who has the
biggest megaphone or the biggest
political voice to
exact Vengeance our job is to serve and
to come up with Solutions together
Republic and Democrat to solve our
nation's problems Professor pey with
impeaching secretary marus over policy
differences between the Biden
Administration and House Republicans
solve any problems facing our
country I don't believe it would the
president retains exclusive
constitutional power to replace
secretary mycus with another official
who he would charge with pursuing
exactly the same policies here is it is
it a bit disingenuous to
suggest that somehow this is new the
issues that we're facing are new at the
border and somehow that uh it was
perfect before secretary Marcus took
over um my knowledge just based on
Supreme Court cases of the number of
cases that have Arisen surrounding
executive actions over border policies
and reading the history there suggests
that these problems have existed through
administrations over decades largely
because Congress has enacted
contradictory laws that are impossible
to comply with and multiple
administrations have struggled to
resolve that
contradiction many of the Republicans
complain that the Biden Administration
and secretary Marcus are not doing
enough on immigration border security
fento are crime Professor pearlstein
does Congress have any role in resolving
these long-standing issues if so please
explain thank you uh representative as
I've mentioned before Congress has a
central role um indeed the Supreme Court
has repeatedly held in cases going back
more than a century that congress's
power in this area is plenary meaning
absolute um that is not to say that the
executive doesn't retain under his own
Article 2 Authority enforcement power
but Congress can not only appropriate
funds it can pose conditions on funds
and the opinion FKS are so fond of
citing in the recent Supreme Court cases
uh while impeachment is certainly uh one
power that Congress has oversight
Appropriations the legislative process
Senate confirmations uh withholding
funds and of course centrally elections
um are all tools that are available uh
to Congress and to the American people
to affect change here and our
withholding funds because you are
unhappy with the secretary in any way
helpful to the issues that these two
grieving mothers have faced and others
may continue to face I can't imagine
that it
is I've got a Mr chairman I'd like to
enter this into the record synthetic
opioid overdose deaths soared while
Trump was President not my words this
report of March 2nd
2023 without obje between
2019 and 2020 the last year of Trump's
presidency the increase in drug overdose
deaths from synthetic opioid was at
55% between 20 and 21 the first year of
Joe Biden's presidency the increase in
drug overdose deaths from synthetic
opioid was at
25% not my words I'll enter this into
the record thank you Mr chairman but I
will tell you this this is nothing to be
proud of that one president president
had higher than another but it is a fact
that requires
discussion but it isn't anything to be
proud of because if it were just
1% if it was just one daughter one son
one
child that was
impacted by this horrible drug that's in
our communities now that comes across
our borders now
not necessarily by immigrants but
primarily
by those that are seeking to do harm and
to enter the drug
trade what do we do when we strip off
our party
veils and say let's fix this
issue regardless of our party let's take
away the notion that this one man
secretary Marcus is this Boogeyman and
we send the message to the rest of the
world if we can just get rid of him all
of our problems would go
away it isn't fair it's disingenuous
it's misleading to the American people
they deserve better and we can do better
Mr chairman I
yield gentleman yields a gentleman from
Florida Mr JZ recognized for five
minutes thank you Mr chairman and
um Miss pearlstein U do you believe that
dereliction of Duty is is an impeachable
offense the only uh examples in US
history I cited in my testimony the
words Derek eltion with of Duty weren't
charged they weren't the articles of
impeachment but those circumstances were
where judges the officers in at issue uh
were either chronically drunk or
mentally incapable of performing their
duties or both do you believe that
failure to uphold your oath to protect
the homeline is that an impeachable
offense I don't believe that anybody has
ever been impeached for a fail I've
never I didn't ask the question I said
do you believe that somebody who fails
to uphold their oath to protect the
Homeland is that an impeachable offense
I believe that somebody who acts in his
own interests or the interests of
gaining his own power or in the interest
of a foreign power is impeachable so you
don't think that somebody who fails who
who fails to uphold the to protect the
Homeland and does it in a way there a
direction of Duty you don't believe that
that's impeachable that somehow Congress
doesn't have the right to exercise its
power of impeachment to remove that
individual who is clearly violating his
oath and his der in his duty you don't
think that Congress can do that I don't
know that there's evidence here of derel
I didn't say there's I'm not
asking ma'am I reclaim my time I reclaim
my time I'd like for you to answer my
question not your
question okay my question is very
specific I didn't say about this case
I'm just talking in general all right in
general depending on the circumstances
depending on the violation of the
Constitution it's conceivable yes okay
so if we determine that that Mr Marcus
is deric in his duty and has failed to
uphold his oath to protect the
Homeland in our opinion okay then is
that an impeachable offense again
dereliction of Duty is different from
failure to comply with the oath right to
the extent the oathy of I said both so
well they're two different legal
arguments I'm said both okay so I've
addressed the question be can't you be
guilty of having two doing two things at
the same time I've addressed the impeach
ability of dereliction of Duty okay the
question of the oath is something
separate to the extent it raises an
allegation of a violation of the
Constitution it is potentially
impeachable but here the Supreme Court
has rejected that
argument I don't believe they have but
anyway I I'll move on is
um is a violation of
law is that when when a an individual
clearly violates the
law um is that impeachable offense
depending on the law I guess right I
mean how how serious that law is is that
your
interpretation impeachment right is only
about a certain category of offenses it
only addresses a certain category of
offenses it has to be an offense similar
to treason or bribe
that is an offense against the system of
government not any ordinary criminal
offense something that disrupts the
structure of the Constitution or system
of government very good okay thank you
so
um allowing millions and millions of
people to come into the United States uh
violating uh the clear intent of
Congress when it says that in order to
be paroled in the United States it has
to be done on a Case SL case basis and
you do it on a mass basis that actually
may have something you know to to affect
may affect uh the land it may affect the
uh the structure of government um I
would argue that and so I guess it's up
to the Supreme Court to to determine
that eventually now
um Miss uh Miss Dunn uh let me say that
that you know I feel deeply for for you
and your loss actually in my extended
family we had the same kind of loss U
due to fentanyl
um do you believe that uh that the
multinational criminal organizations the
cartels um that are working Across The
Bard do you believe that they are
terrorist organizations for lack of a
better
word yes sir I do and they're guilty of
mass murder yes sir I do believe that I
and I do too and U and I believe also
one of the things and that that Mr Mar
orcus has shown to be derel in his duty
is the absolute failure of this
Administration to combat
what I consider to be a multi be
terrorist organizations which are the
the Mexican drug drug cartels that
control the border and by the way I also
believe the Biden Administration is
actually helping those uh
organizations um by not stemming the
flow of illegal
immigration uh they are enriching those
multinational organizations to the tune
tune of billions of dollars which allows
them to produce more fentanyl which
which allows them to kill tens of
thousands of American citizens and so
for that too I believe that Mr mayorcas
has failed miserably in his duty to
protect them the Homeland and with that
my time has expired and I yield back
thank
you gentleman
yields
magazine Mr tadar recognized for five
minutes for
question thank you Mr
chair and I want to thank
uh all of our Witnesses here
today my sincere condolences to our
witnesses as a father and a
grandfather I sympathize with your
unimaginable
loss as a member of
Congress I realize it is my duty and my
colleagues duty to do all we can to
prevent strategies like this from
impacting our
communities that is why one of my first
act as a freshman member of Congress was
introducing an amendment to the
Republicans hr2 border
bill which they are now threatening to
shut the government down
over which aimed to bolster the
Department of Homeland Security's
efforts to combat crossborder threats
posed by transnational criminal
organizations this amendment which would
have strengthened DHS ability to combat
organizations engaging in criminal
activity such as uh drug trafficking and
human smuggling was voted down by every
single Republican
member citing in this hearing room today
sitting in this hearing room today and
on this
committee while Republicans voted this
and every other Democratic Amendment
down I know enacting meaningful
legislation is needed to address the
issues at the southern
border that's why I have introduced the
United against transnational criminal
organization ations act several of my
Democratic colleagues on this committee
have signed on to this bill which
directs DSS to take a range of actions
to combat illicit criminal Cal activity
that undermines our homeland security
the bill directs DHS to establish a
Joint Task Force bringing together
multiple agency components to conduct
operations to combat crossborder threats
posed by tcos and organizations engaged
in the trafficking of fentel and its
materials across the land border of
us this bill directs DHS to establish an
integrated border intelligence
analytical cell to improve information
sharing regarding the concentrated surge
of migration smuggling and
trafficking and since we know a vast
amount of fental is traffi through our
ports of Entry it requires DHS to issue
a strategy to improve the effectiveness
of the screening of vehicles persons and
cargo at land ports of Entry that are at
high risk of being related to
transnational criminal
organizations my question to you
Professor
polston would you agree that a
legislation such as my United against
transnational criminal organizations Act
is a more effective
measure to solving the issues at our
border versus U impeaching a
secretary over policy
differences thank you uh Mr tanar again
I'm not a immigration policy expert but
the bill that you propose is certainly
within congress's power to enact uh it
may have an effect on immigration policy
impeachment will have no effect on
immigration policy thank you and Mr
chair are you
back gentlemen yields a gentleman from
Texas Mr fluger is recognized for five
minutes for questioning thank you Mr
chair Miss Nobles and Miss dun I'm so
sorry for your
loss we we can't even fathom the loss
that you've gone
through and your courage to be here to
speak out to bring light to the
situation to speak the truth is not only
commended but it's necessary so that we
avoid this pain for other
families thank you for being
here
um Professor pearlstein are you familiar
with the William bellnap case that you
mentioned in your testimony are you very
like you're intimately
familiar with it as a constitutional law
expert I'm generally familiar with the
bellnap impeachment yes you wrote about
it in your testimony correct I did yes
is there a reason that you left out the
fact that article three of that
impeachment case mentioned the
disregarding of his duty as Secretary of
War no was it particularly helpful to
your argument
today uh I'm not sure what the question
is was there a reason you left that out
I wasn't giving a full book report on
the bellnap impeachment I was mentioning
it in my testimony that's fine um as the
only other instance in US history in
which Congress has ever right in article
three of that thank you that's the only
other history what we're talking about
is unprecedented disregarding of his
duty I'm going to quote
you there the professors were reasonably
uniformed and recognizing that it
doesn't have to be a crime that is to
say an impeachable offense doesn't have
to be a crime as currently embodied in
the federal criminal code AS enacted by
Congress what they were thinking about
with the impeachment remedy were serious
offenses against the public
trust that is certain things that only
the president and other senior officials
could do that abuse their Authority did
you in fact say this with regards to the
Trump impeachment I've I've said many
things about impeachment I don't it's
entirely possible that I said that and I
I would still agree with it actually uh
Mr chairman I'd like to insert for the
record Professor pearlstein's comments
on a radio show in New York on a podcast
in 2019 regarding the Trump
administration's without objection so
ordered thank you um so do you believe
will you Define impeachment um with
regards to the public trust as you said
it there with regards to Trump if the
public public trust is broken is that an
impeachable offense public trust in this
context refers to two kinds of reaches
of the public trust generally one is a
official who is acting in his own
personal interest right to Grise his own
political wealth interests power Etc as
opposed to the interests of the American
people that's an example of a breach of
the public trust the other is if an
official is acting on behalf of a
foreign power which is another example
of a breach of a public trust yes and I
thought those issues were both
implicated in the Trump Ukraine
impeachment do you believe that public
trust has been broken with regards to
the common defense of our
country as a general matter the
collective defense of our country as a
general matter I'm not I'm not sure I
can answer that question that broadly
stated has the public I'm not aware of
any evidence for example the secretary
my orcus has been acting for his own
personal welf for ab brisement that
that's fine but in
general is breaking the public trust in
an egregious manner grounds for an
impeachment proceeding in the way I just
defined breaking the public trust that
is acting on behalf of One's Own
interest as opposed to the interests of
the public yes that can be an
impeachable ground if there is evidence
of that are are you uh licensed in a
state am I member of the bar do you mean
the bar yeah yes I'm a member of the bar
of the State of California and I'm a
member of the bar of Washington DC is it
your responsibility to uphold the laws
in those States in which you are a
member of the bar I have all of the same
ethical obligations that any attorney
has when you take the oath of office as
a Cabinet member to well and Faithfully
execute the duties of the office does
that infer a responsibility to uphold
the laws as
well anybody who takes an oath to take
care that the laws are Faithfully
executed has an oath to to take care of
that the laws are Faithfully executed
yes did you condemn the attacks by Hamas
on
Israel I'm not sure what that has to do
with anything it's a question did you
condemn the attacks my personal view of
those attacks is that they were abhorent
I don't think I've had occasion to speak
about it publicly it's not my area of
expertise Mr chair i y back thank you
gentlemen y i now recognize Mr magaziner
for the gentleman from Rhode Island for
his five minutes of questioning
thank you chairman and I want to thank
our Witnesses for Having the courage to
share their stories and their expertise
today we have real challenges at the
border I I've been there I've seen it
and I know that the American people are
counting on Congress to act
unfortunately too many of my Republican
colleagues are more focused on playing
politics instead of working together to
address our problems the Biden
Administration has requested $14 billion
to secure the Border funding that would
hire more than 1,300 border patrol
agents and more than a thousand CBP
officers House Republicans have refused
to call a vote on this funding for
nearly four months they have sat on this
proposal for nearly four months
undercutting their claim that they
really care about border security if you
care about it call a vote and if you
don't like all of the proposal call a
vote on the parts that you do like when
House Republicans were asked why they
won't call a vote on the president's
border funding request one of them said
quote let me tell you I'm not willing to
do too damn much right now to help a
Democrat and to help Joe Biden's
approval rating that tells you all you
need to know he was more concerned about
Joe Biden's approval rating than about
fixing the problems at the border and
he's not the only one Laura Ingram on
Fox news said that Republicans should
not accept any border deal because it
would be quote a victory for Biden even
speaker Johnson has openly mused that
House Republicans will not accept more
border funding until there is a
Republican president now some of my
colleagues say well funding's not enough
we need policy changes at the border too
okay over the last month through the
holidays secretary my orcus has been
working diligently with Senate
Republicans and Senate Democrats to try
to come up with a policy plan for the
Border where have House Republicans been
in those talks Mia not participating
they gave themselves a vacation for a
month well imagine imagine if the
reverse were the truth imagine if House
Republicans were actually working with
the Senate on a border plan and
secretary my orcus decided to go on
vacation for a month what would people
say about that instead you know this
phrase dereliction of Duty gets thrown
around a lot it is my house Republican
colleagues who have been derelict in
their Duty they have refused to call a
vote on Border funding for four months
they have refused to participate in the
talks with the secretary and the Senate
to put a border plan together what have
they been doing instead playing
politics they passed a budget plan the
so-called limit save grow act which
would have cut the Department of
Homeland Security by 22% eliminating
2,000 CBP officers at the border every
one of them voted for that when the
Biden Administration requested 84
million to help states and cities with
the costs associated with migration
House Republicans instead cut it to
zero some House Republicans have openly
called for shutting down the government
this week even though they know that
that means that border patrol agents who
are already overworked and underpaid
would be forc forced to work without any
pay at all and now they are playing
politics with impeachment even though
there is no legal basis for impeaching
the secretary I've heard that this is
going to be our final impeachment
hearing and still House Republicans have
yet to clearly articulate what laws they
think the secretary has broken they have
not brought in a single legal expert who
is willing to put up their hand and
under oath state that there is a sound
legal basis for impeachment the best
they could do last week was a handful of
Republican
politicians they invited the secretary
to appear in a hearing to defend himself
against their ambiguous charges and then
when he sent a letter back on January
11th saying that he would appear they
reneged on his invitation and disinvited
him but the sad thing about these
political games is that this is wasted
time this is time that we could be
spending to work together on real
solutions for the Border real solutions
to solve the fentel crisis real
solutions to combat the cartels and
create a safe and orderly system at the
border Senate Democrats are working on
it as we speak Senate Republicans are
working on it as we speak the secretary
is working on it as we speak and it is
only House Republicans who are putting
politics ahead of doing the work to
solve our problems Professor for those
of us who are serious about trying to
improve the situation at the border is
impeachment congress's most effective
tool to do it or are there other powers
that Congress has that would be better
suited to fixing the situation at the
border thank you Congressman as I've
said impeachment in this context will
have no effect on Administration or
American Border policy Congress has a
host of tools at its disposal as the
Supreme Court recently listed and i' as
as I've testified to including of course
Appropriations oversight hearings
legislative process Senate confr
formations withholding funds and then of
course as I as I've mentioned before
elections there are others as well thank
you Professor how you back gentlemen y
um we're going to take a 10-minute break
to give our witnesses an opportunity to
uh take a break and we will reconvene at
uh we'll we'll say
11:40 the committee is adour or is uh in
recess
get uh get seated and get going there be
great members who are tying up our
Witnesses
committee will come to order I now
recognize the gentle lady from Georgia
Mrs Green for her five minutes of
testimony thank you Mr chairman uh so
far today on this this very important
historic hearing we've listened to
Democrats complain that Republicans have
had have done nothing to stop the border
security crisis pretending that we
didn't pass hr2 the strongest border
bill that has ever been passed in
Congress all of our Democrat colleagues
voted no to that bill my Democrat
colleagues today are complaining that
they need more money well it seems to be
from listening on these on this
committee most of the time they want
more money to help more migrants ANS
come into the country it's unfortunate
that it's about migrants it should be
about
Americans I've also listened to them
talk about
impeachment talking about impeachment
saying that impeachment is not the right
thing to do when it comes to Secretary
of Mayor is complaining about
impeachment hearings but I'd like to
remind everyone that when they impeached
president Trump they introduced article
of impeachment on January 11th held zero
hearings and then passed these articles
of impeachment on January 13th oh my oh
my the
hypocrisy but let's talk a little bit
further let's talk about something I
heard from one of our Witnesses today
saying that impeachment is needed or
necessary or warranted when this person
has acted in the interest of a foreign
power that that's an impeachable offense
well let's talk about how we could argue
secretary morcus has has definitely
acted for a foreign
power former special agent for dea's
Special Operations Division testified
under oath that the cartels have control
over the United States Southern border
the cartels not our government not our
border patrol that's a foreign power HS
and coyotes are making around 13 billion
a year in human trafficking alone off
Joe Biden's open border policies and
secretary
mayor's willful willful disobedience in
his job the revenue is 26 times more
than cartel's earned under President
Trump 26 times
more that would definitely be helping a
foreign power I'm sure that money is
spent in countries like Mexico that
helps their
economy cartels control approximately
40% of Mexico the cartels do that means
that this border crisis and the laws
that are being broken are definitely in
the interest of a foreign
power now we're also hearing a debate
back and forth about policy is it a
policy difference or is it secretary May
oris's Disobedience and and his
willfulness to break our federal laws I
ask that question because I want to know
is it the Biden administration's policy
to kill 300 Americans every single day
to
fentel is it the Biden administration's
policy that cartel members are allowed
to come in our country and are released
these are these are unaccompanied
miners are they allowed by the Biden
administration's policy to come in the
country and rape and murder young women
is it the Biden administration's policy
for nearly
100,000 unaccompanied minor children to
go missing in our
country is it the Biden administration's
policy for child labor migrant child
labor that was talked about in the New
York Times is that the Biden
administration's policy if so then maybe
we shouldn't be having hearings on my
articles of impeachment to impeach
secretary mayorcas maybe we should be
holding articles of impeachment on the
president of the United States is that
where we're going what do you think
about that Miss pearlstein do you think
is it a policy difference or is it
secretary mayorcas which one Biden Joe
Biden or secretary
morcus my impression of the allegations
that the majority has raised here is
that they are entirely about policy
differences with Miss pearlstein you've
talked about policy in your testimony
today policy so that would be Joe Biden
I'm sure you voted for him for president
you're you've been talking about the
Biden administration's policy has been
the cause of all of this so is it Joe
Biden's policy the administration's
policy or is it secretary
mayorcas the Constitution no matter
which official Miss pearlstein ask your
question is it the Biden Administration
or is it secretary mayorcas not the
Constitution we're not talking about the
Constitution is it the Biden
administration's open border policies or
is it secretary meorc is breaking
federal law one or the other because the
statistics are clear are you capable of
answering that
question I'm not sure those were about
four questions no it's one or the other
Biden Administration open border
policies or secretary Americus one or
the other what who caused it that has
caused 300 Americans to die every single
day these two women women sitting next
to you's daughters have been murdered
we're talking about over a 100,000 I'm
sorry nearly 100,000 unaccompanied
miners missing in this country we are
talking about cartel members everywhere
the cartel controlling the southern
border we're talking about the massive
increase in statistics it's either one
or the other it's either the Biden
administration's open border policies or
it's secretary
morcus ma'am I'm constitutional law no
point to the Constitution all right so
we're a little over
here gent lady y thank you Mr chairman I
now recognize Mr ivy for his five
minutes questioning thank you Mr
chairman um I'd like to start off we're
going to show a clip from an interview
uh that involved former secretary uh
Sher off and I wanted to play that now
if we
can
I'd like for you both very quickly to
weigh in on what happens if the
Republican Le Congress goes ahead with
this vow to impeach or try to impeach
the current Secretary of Homeland
Security does that mean all the things
you suggested don't happen and Congress
is just tied knots secretary
chot well it would be a very sad day if
in in search of what is again a
political stunt you know threatening to
impeach secretary mayorcas Congress
didn't do the things for example that
secretary Johnson just suggested maybe
adjust the standard with respect to
Asylum create more resources that are
available to adjudicate and work out
additional ways to fund the effort to
undermine the cartels and the Smugglers
which are a big part of this so it would
be basically putting form over substance
to go through a big performance on
impeachment that's never going anywhere
rather than actually working with the
administration to solve the
problem thank you and then shortly after
that uh former secretary Johnson said we
can't have a secretary who's distracted
by a stunt in Congress and and attempted
impeachment um similarly we've had other
quotes um I
think Congressman Ken Buck a republican
Congressman who's raised similar
concerns about
well who stated basically there's no
grounds for impeachment uh and uh also
Professor Jonathan Turley who uh
testified and Charley's important here
because he's the witness that the
Republicans called to testify uh at the
oversight hearing that made Miss green I
think was referencing with respect to
President Biden uh and he said that uh
at you know at that hearing that there
was no evidence to impeach President
Biden
he sent us a letter to this committee
saying the same thing with respect to
secretary May orcus
thanks so I I want to sort of point out
a couple of things here with respect to
that um to the extent we've had hearings
uh that have discussed this issue of
impeachment uh from a legal standard
from a constitutional standpoint the
only Witnesses who've actually addressed
it directly are U Professor Bowman who
testified at the last hearing and
Professor pearlstein who's testified
today there's no testimony to the
contrary that they provided that was
given by the witnesses um that the
Republicans have called and I I suggest
that that's in part or maybe in whole
because they don't have experts who will
come in and say legal experts
constitutional Scholars who are
experienced with respect to impeachment
will come here and raise their right
hand and swear under oath that uh the
Constitution justifies impeachment with
respect to Secret AR mayorcas in this
case uh and the absence of the testimony
the ranking member raised due process
issues at the beginning of the hearing I
would suggest that um this goes to the
heart of it if there's no evidence that
the Republicans have presented about um
actual impeachment uh the standard in
the Constitution being violated we
should not be moving forward with
impeachment under these circumstances
also note Professor pearlstein's uh
testimony the point about even if you if
you don't like the policies that
secretary
mayorcas is uh
implementing uh and you impeach him and
the Senate removes him which they're not
gonna we've already heard from Senators
over there who've said you're wasting
the time let's focus on actual
legislation that they're trying to work
out and get done um but even if you
remove him President Biden's just going
to move up the acting administrator I
suppose uh acting uh secretary who would
continue to imple implement the same
policy so it's a waste of time as uh
secretary cherof called it it's a
political stunt but more importantly I
mean it is a total distraction from
actually trying to get the legislation
done it's hard to ignore the fact that
the Senate is having bipartisan
negotiations on the behalf of the the
Democrats and the Republicans to try and
pass a bill or put together a bill that
would address these issues the White
House is working with them house
Democrats are working with them only the
House Republicans are no shows they did
the the field trip to uh the border and
did the photo op and send it back uh but
they've haven't decided to move forward
with actually fixing the issues on that
front just the last point I'll make on
that front hr2 there's a lot of talk
about that's been passed and it's
sitting on uh you know the U Schumer's
desk uh but it's not on his desk it's in
the trash can and you know what it's in
McConnell's trash can to and they said
that before it was passed through they
said you got all these poison pill
Provisions in here we're not going to
move this send this something we can
actually work with you didn't so now
they're trying to put a bill together
and everybody's on board with with that
effort except House Republicans so if we
really want to get something done let's
all come together and work on it so we
can pass legislation that addresses the
problem and with that I yield back
gentleman yields I now recognize Mr Isel
the gentleman from Mississippi for his 5
minutes questioning thank you Mr
chairman and thank you all our Witnesses
today for for being here and providing
this important information that we need
uh Mr Nobles uh thank you for joining us
here today and I can't imagine how tough
it is must be discussing this over and
over again about the May orcas spell uh
border security policy I generally
appreciate you sharing the challenging
stories and emphasizing the importance
of border security Americans are
demanding in we do something well over
40 years in law enforcement including
the sheriff I truly understand how
challenging it is to ensure the safety
of our communities I never stopped
slowed down and prevented my officers
from enforcing the law I swore an O to
protect the citizens of my community
somehow secretary May orcus is making
this tough job even tougher for our men
and women at border patrol this stes a
report from the house Judiciary
Committee pointed out several failures
in vetting your daughter's killer when
he crossed the border the report showed
your daughter's murder was arrested for
associations with MS13 long before he
came to the United States something that
could have been verified with a simple
phone call but our members of border
patrol uh are are not being allowed to
do their jobs they told me this
personally when we were down there last
year instead there are nurse mating and
making sand sandwiches for criminals
while all this stuff goes on and uh you
know the buck stops at the top this
could have immediately disqualified this
killer from getting in the country had
they been able to do their jobs but they
have been hired to do the report also
noted that he was released after he was
arrested for murder Mr Noble do you have
any reason to believe that secretary
morcus has taken these reports
seriously no he hasn't
to me the reports are clear his policies
are failing do you believe he's trying
to change the process of the vetting
illegal aliens coming across our border
no if he was then my daughter would
still be here today if they did their
jobs they did not do their jobs it's no
secret how gruesome and violent the
cartels are I've seen it personally
myself in many cases they are even
better armed than local law enforcement
and your opening state statement you
quote this isn't about immigration this
is about protecting everyone in the
United States of America again the
American citizens are demanding that we
take action Miss nobl do you believe
that secretary mea's policies are
strengthening the
cartels do you believe that his policies
are strengthening
cartels no mother father should ever
have to endure hearing chilling news
that their child has been a victim of
such a violent heinous crime crime
unfortunately as a sheriff I have
delivered these devastating news to
families it's one of the most difficult
things you'll ever do as a law
enforcement officer to end I will simply
ask do you believe this crisis has been
created by the Biden administration's
policies yes thank you again and thank
you all for being here today we will
continue to be your voice we will
continue to take action and no matter
what the other side says we're going to
do something to stop this thank you Mr
chairman I yield back the gentleman
yields I now recognize Miss Ramirez uh
the gentle lady from Illinois for her 5
minutes of
questioning thank you chairman and
ranking
member I want to begin by acknowledging
the loss is here today Miss Noble's MISD
done I am grieved that you have endured
losing your daughters Kayla Marie and
Ashley no parent should ever have to go
through this loss no
parent I I also want to acknowledge the
losses that are not described today I
want to name a couple of those bigma de
lasanas ceros 33y old mother JL Ruby 10
years old and Jonathan Austine bones de
las sancha eight years old they lost
their lives when cruel policy choices
and willful obstruction of
intergovernmental coordination by the
Abbot Administration in Texas kept
border patrol Agents from responding to
rescue a drowning mother and her
children Mr chairman I would like to ask
unanimous consent to enter these two
articles into the record three migrants
including two children drowned near the
Texas border and a 8-year-old migrant
died after a week in US detention
without objection so ordered thank you
anad Rees Alvarez an 8-year-old who
passed away on May 2023 at a c BP
Detention Facility in Texas when medical
staff failed to review her medical
documentation and provide access to a
physician and Emergency Care there are
so many examples of the consequences of
a cold disregard for a shared Humanity
in the absence of compassion there's
just so much pain and it's across our
communities immigration statuses
political identities when it comes to
the humanitarian crisis within our
borders and the cost of congressional
inaction you see I just got back from
from Guatemala where I heard painful
stories that underline the need to act
beyond our borders to address the root
causes of migration what causes a nine a
12 year old to cross all of Guatemala
all of Mexico in hope to get to our
Southern border what do we do to create
legal Pathways and how do we understand
the root cause of migration I heard
about children who are hungry
impoverished desperate to meet the needs
of their families
willing to leave Villages cross jungles
deserts and rivers and die in Rio
Grande just to make it to the US I heard
about the pain and Trauma of Separation
isolation detention and deportation I
saw how corruption corporate land grabs
environmental destruction and disaster
Democratic backsliding create conditions
that drive migration pain that shows us
where healing is needed the pain that
was shared with me in Guatemala requires
healing that could be Advanced by
congressional action congressional
action that addresses and prepares for
climate migration invest in economic
development of La Latin American
countries modernizes legal Pathways to
citizenship strengthens democracy and
combats corruption in Latin America you
see the pain of an Aid's death requires
healing that could be Advanced by
congressional action like establishing
humanitarian standards at CBP sites
granting immigration parole improving
adjudicatory processing capacity or
increasing Personnel to reduce USCIS
backlogs the pain ofma jorl and
Jonathan's death requires healing that
could be in advance by congressional
action we could increase board Personnel
to expand screening and assistance to
new
arrivals the pain of families traffic by
Abbot must be addressed by implemen pres
ing Federal coordination or resettlement
to Interior cities expanding work
permits to heal we have to actually talk
about comprehensive immigration reform
and have a conversation why are
thousands of people wanting to cross our
Southern border Professor prostin the
testimonies we heard today show how
critical it is that we take policy
action yes or
no I think these policies are of
enormous pressing public importance yes
and just for the record for the 10th
time maybe if impeachments are not an
instrument for affecting policy changes
is there a legitimate basis for this
impeachment yes or no I don't believe
the Constitution supports impeachment in
this case thank you you see Republicans
are not interested in advancing policy
change if they were they would stop
these impeachment hearings and work with
us to pass legislation even one of the
many things I talked about sit down with
us and actually work on it but according
to speaker Johnson Congress can't solve
border until Trump is elected or
republican is back in the white house I
mean think about how politicized this
moment
is they are parading our parade for
their political purposes
enough as I said if we are serious about
this process and this solution we would
be capable to respect people's humanity
and move us to a collaborative approach
where our neighboring countries were
able to address the root cause keep
Community safe and honor the very fabric
of our multi-racial Multicultural
democracy that's what we would be doing
today thank you chairman and ranking
member and I yield back with hope gent
lady yields I now recognize Mr Diaz
bazito the gentleman from New York for
his five minutes question well thank you
Mr chairman and uh thank you to the
witnesses this
morning it seems that uh the other side
of the aisle is talking about making
this
impeachment about politics and I will
tell you that this has absolutely
nothing to do with politics and
everything to do with the American
people miss pearlstein you mentioned in
the recording that our chairman
plead that the founding
fathers talked and what they described
in the constitution is not what we focus
on right now always you quote said
serious offenses against the public
trust could lead to an
impeachment so Mrs dun do you
believe that what has occurred and what
happened to your daughter and other
teenagers and Americans throughout this
country just like her do you believe
that that is a serious offense against
the public Trust
yes my border not being secure is a
serious offense other legislators
worried about other people from other
countries instead of my own is a serious
offense I I take great offense to that I
think you need to be worried about us
thank you and M Miss Nobles the same
question do you feel that what happened
uh to your daughter and the crimes that
have been committed against Americans by
individuals who have illegally crossed
our border do you think that those are
serious offenses against the public
trust yes
definitely so secretary mayorcas and his
failed border policies have placed all
Americans in danger every state is a
border state and every state has seen
the impact of the crisis at our Southern
border it's what we've outlined over the
five phases in this
committee proud to be a retired nyp
detective having spent a career
upholding my oath to protect and serve
the
places that I kept safe that solemn oath
is now that much harder for law
enforcement throughout this country have
been put on the front lines of this
crisis as a direct result of the failed
policies of secretary
mayorcas as I just stated every state is
a border state and Miss Nobles your
daughter was tragically murdered in
Maryland well over a th000 miles from
the southern border I know that the man
who murdered your daughter was a
well-known MS13 gang member in 2018
president Trump came to Long Island with
then Congressman Peter King to discuss
MS13 and the heinous crimes they commit
both on Long Island and throughout this
country you see back then we had an
Administration who actively worked to
find solutions to the issues occurring
at our Southern border they worked with
law enforcement to make sure that they
had the tools necessary to protect and
serve their communities and now we have
secretary mayorcas who has have put all
Americans in
danger in Nassau County we have
identified
271 ident uh MS-13
members Miss Nobles do you believe that
secretary mayorcas has taken adequate
measures to ensure MS-13 members
and other members of criminal
organizations are not able to enter this
nation Le illegally no absolutely
not miss Dunn just this morning I spoke
with commissioner Pat Ryder who's the
commissioner of the Nassau County Police
Department my district well over
thousands of miles from the southern
border is still seeing dozens of
overdoses each week with drugs flowing
from our Southern border we know that it
takes an incredibly small amount of
fentol to kill someone and harm families
and
communities do you know the amount of
fent fentanyl that killed your
daughter sir my daughter used one half
of one tablet that she believed was per
cassette in that one half of one tablet
there was 5 milligrams of fentin enough
to kill two and a half people
two and a half people correct in five
milligrams yes and since May orcus has
been the Secretary of Homeland Security
25 billion milligrams of fentol has come
across our Southern border and
unfortunately has killed many others
tragically just like your daughter yes
it is very
clear that America and the people who
live here are at risk and sec secretary
mayorcas deserves to be impeached
because he has committed serious
offenses against the public Trust of the
United States of America Mr chairman I
yield back gentleman yields I now
recognize a gentleman from New York Mr
Goldman for five minutes questioning
thank you very much Mr chairman and I I
thank our Witnesses uh for being here
today Miss Nobles and Miss Dunn uh I
just want to express uh my sincere
condolences I was a federal prosecutor
for 10 years who charged people for Gang
Related and drug trafficking crimes um
unfortunately this is not the first time
I've had to interact with families of
victims and my heart goes out to you and
I I just want I want to apologize in
some ways to you that you are here um
really to share your story but you're
being used in as a fact witness for an
impeachment um
investigation and obviously given you
know what your experience has been you
don't have the background um to
understand what a high crime misdemeanor
is and how it relates to this and so I I
hope that um you're you're handling that
okay um you know one of the things that
the chairman said at the beginning of
his opening statement
was uh that he wishes that Democrats
would turn our sympathy into
action uh and quite ironically said
thoughts and prayers are not enough at
first I thought we were at a gun
violence um hearing where uh we were
talking about the repeated thoughts and
prayers of the two mass shootings that
happen every day but uh I do want to
just go through some of the uh actions
as as the chairman pointed out turn
sympathy into action um because I assume
Miss D you you would agree would you not
that it would help to stop the fenel
trade and fenal trafficking from coming
into this country if we had more law
enforcement officers at the border and
more resources and Technology to stop
the fenel from coming in do you agree
with that I disagree with that because
border patrol is now being used to make
sandwiches and to screen people and let
them into our country okay well so so I
disagree with you so you're you're
saying that
the you're so you're saying that uh
you're upset because the border patrol
is not doing uh is making sandwiches I
think you said so you don't think it
would be helpful to have more border
patrol officers who are charged with
stopping the fenel trade I would like
the border patrol to be able to do the
job that they were hired to do well one
way every border patrol officer that I
have spoken to has told me that their
hands are tied by this Administration
and Mr mayorcas I've been to the Border
sir have you the have you I'm Excuse me
I'm asking the question I'm just
wondering and the the the the problem
with that is that um in Congress this
this Congress we have um interviewed
nine senior officials uh of the under
DHS in in a variety of different
capacities um every single one of them
has said that it would be helpful to
provide more resources at the border to
stop the flow of fenal coming in and
that is actually exactly what President
Biden has done uh in last year's budget
fiscal year 2023 the
Appropriations um included 300
additional US border patrol agents which
was the first increase since
2011 included 12 25 more CBP officers
$70 million for non-intrusive inspection
and 200 House Republicans including
every single Republican serving at the
time who currently sits on this
committee voted against that bill under
the Biden Administration the Department
of Homeland Security has seized more
fenel and arrested more criminals for
fenel related crimes in the last two
years than in the previous 5 years
combined and even in this Congress when
we had the Department of Homeland
Security Appropriations markup Mr kareah
offered an amendment that would provide
more money and more uh resources for the
border to stop the fenel trade and every
single Republican voted it down but
that's not it even with the supplemental
request from the White House they
requested $1.2 billion to crack down on
the the trafficking of dangerous and
lethal illicit drugs like fentanyl
including over $300 million for the most
effective non-intrusive inspection
systems and of course 90% of fenel comes
through the ports of Entry so having
those inspection systems would do it
again the Republicans will not support
the border with additional resources to
do the job that the secretary wants to
do and so we are here yet again for a
political stunt to make an argument that
this Administration is not doing
anything even as it is negotiating to
try to address the problems at the
border and even as it is trying to
increase the number of Border agents and
Technology to address the fenel system
let's stop this sham impeachment hearing
and let's go negotiate with the Senate
and the White House who are doing that
right now with secretary my orcus to
address the problems at the border I
yield back gentleman yields I now
recognize the gentleman from North
Carolina Mr Bishop for his five minutes
questioning thank you Mr chairman uh
Miss Don I was watching you as we uh
listened to my friend from New York just
now and and heard what you said you did
a fantastic job sort of uh defeating his
point in the little bit of time he gave
you but as he was saying that what that
they make the issue that Republicans
aren't sending more money to the Border
uh what every jurisic in the United
States notably New York Chicago and
others are suffering is an Deluge of
immigrants that the country cannot
assimilate that are not prepared to be
assimilated culturally by by linguistic
Background by experience they're not we
can't get it get the job done that way
the only proposals that Democrats have
offered let this go down on record the
only proposals that have been offered is
to send more money to the border which
will be used to process more immigrants
faster into the country number one one
or number two to legalize them all grant
them amnesty as if that would somehow
address any of the problems that we're
experiencing not one of them would be
addressed so I appreciate miss nobl you
and Miss dun you for being here it must
be ex particularly infuriating to hear
that when you've suffered the
ultimate uh victimhood from the
violations of law that the Secretary of
Homeland Security has administered so
miss professor pey I want to go to you
though because I want to talk about talk
about that victim the rule of
law um you said in your
paper in defense of secretary my orcus
that to the extent the majority of
reports allegations against the
secretary are related to those policies
in particular the suggestion that
secretary my orcus somehow exceeded the
scope of his lawful authority to set
priorities for the enforcement of US
immigration law that claim has been
rejected Ed most recently by an
overwhelming bipartisan majority of the
US Supreme
Court now are you referring to the
United States Tech versus Texas case
from last June I am but there the the
majority opinion says quote we take no
position on whether the executive branch
here is complying with its legal
obligations we hold only that the
federal courts are not the proper Forum
to resolve this dispute so when you read
that language how do you come to the
conclusion that the court decided that
secretary mayorcas is acting in
accordance with his legal
responsibilities the basis of the
Court's ruling on standing that you just
described was as Justice Kavanaugh's
opinion for the majority said the
authority to decide how to prioritize
and how aggressively to pursue legal
actions against defendants belongs to
the executive branch under article two
that was the basis of the ruling that
was there is no standing in this case
well they also said they taken no
position whether the executive branch is
complying with it legal obligation
appointed said this is Authority that
belongs exclusively to the executive
branch right what you're referring to is
the court says we're not in the business
of refereeing anything where the
executive has any amount of
prosecutorial discretion but they also
say we're not deciding here whether the
executive branch is complying with its
legal obligations both of those
propositions are true they're both in
the opinion are they not ma'am the court
found that there was no standing ma' I
asked you a question this proposition is
in the opinion as well correct I read it
it's accurate the court found there was
no standing that is also true I didn't
ask you about standing I asked you
whether this language that I just read
where the court said we're not
determining whether the executive branch
is complying with its legal obligations
that's also in the Court's opinion
correct that may be in the Court's
opinion but that's what I asked thank
you let me ask you this at the oral
argument this was Justice Kavanaugh's
question to the solicitor general
solicitor general of the United States I
think your position is instead of
judicial review Congress has to resort
to shutting down the government or
impeachment or dramatic steps if it if
some Administration comes in and says
we're not going to enforce laws or at
least not going to enforce the laws to
the degree that Congress by law has said
the laws should be enforced and that's
forcing I mean I understand your
position but it's forcing Congress to
take dramatic steps isn't that what he
said at oral argument I don't have the
transcript of oral argument all right do
you disagree with his proposition as I
just recited it to you justice Leo said
in his lone descent that impeachment
along with funding C offs and others
were among the potentially available
remedies that Congress has the majority
opinion none of the other eight justices
including all of the justices appointed
by the former president mentioned
impeachment in that context so you're
aware are you familiar with the illegal
immigration reform and immigration
responsibility Act of
1996 it's a large act which part the
part that the that the United States
Supreme Court considered in United
States versus Texas I've read the case
okay you know that as Justice Alo
describes in The Descent that in that
situation the Congress decided to re
withdraw some of the discretion that the
executive has by requiring detention and
uh specifically in certain cases
right what the court said was that for
the last 27 years since these laws that
law was enacted in their current form
all five presidential administrations
have determined the resource constraints
necessitated prioritization in making
immigration addr rests if you evaded a
question like that before the bench they
would not like it I Y back Mr shair my
time's expired the gentleman yields I
now recognize a gentleman from
California Mr swell for his five minutes
questioning appreciate that uh thank you
chairman first I I want to
um thank Miss Nobles and Miss Dunn Mrs
Dunn for testifying and express my
condolences for uh the loss of your
children and to tell you that I have
constituents as well who have lost uh
children uh to Fentanyl and I know it's
not easy to come to Congress and to talk
about it and I hope that what you will
find one day is a Congress that will
unite and do everything it can uh to
make sure that we reduce uh these deaths
um I also wish we could hear from
secretary my orcus uh because uh he has
stated he wants to come and testify and
I know Mr magaziner put into the record
a letter from Mr my orcus uh stating
that he again would be willing to
testify he's testified 27 times to
Congress more than any other cabinet
official uh and twice uh last year
before this uh committee uh and he has
made his senior uh officials uh
available
um and to the witnesses who have come
here today if you came looking for an
audience uh that is serious and wants
you know to take up this issue I'm
afraid you're in the wrong place I'm
afraid that when it comes
to immigration Solutions uh too many of
my colleagues would rather have the
issue uh than the fix and I am speaking
for myself here and I know I probably
speak for many of my colleagues uh I I
don't want open borders I want a secure
border that's why I have supported
surging more border agents uh at the
border that's why I support deploying
more uh Technologies at the border
that's why I support having more
barriers uh at the border uh and that's
why I want to make sure that we also
address the workforce crisis in America
uh by you know increasing legal
immigration uh and increasing you know
immigrants who can work the jobs that
Americans are just not going to work so
we can reduce the cost cost and give
more financial breathing room to
families uh in this country you're not
going to find that here this is not
where they do that this is where they
seek Fame uh rather than a fix and what
you're going to find here is
that if we were to solve this crisis
this committee wouldn't have anything uh
to talk about and and that's more
important uh to the speaker uh of this
house and that's more important uh to
the person that too many of them rely
upon uh when they make DEC Visions which
is the former uh president I want to
just give you a couple examples uh
Sergeant danels I'm sorry he can't be
here today because last time he was here
I asked him if he would support
additional border patrol agents as the
Senate passed with 68 Republicans and
Democrats uh not too long ago and he
said he would and and I would like to
have unanimous consent to enter into the
record his written testimony to our
committee and to the oversight committee
where he said that that objection so
ordered so then you have have just
recently on CNN Jake Tapper asked
speaker Johnson look President Biden
wants to give you more money at the
border uh would you take that and
speaker johnon said no again just
revealing and saying out loud what we
all know which is that they don't want
to solve this problem they they want to
use it and exploit it and exploit
victims so they have a political
narrative Senate negotiations are taking
place right now where in good faith
Democrats and Republicans are working to
try and find more solutions
and more resources at the border and
that is Dead on Arrival here where
Republican colleagues have said out loud
we're never going to support that that
would help the president they've
actually said
that my Democratic colleagues want the
fix Maga Republicans want the fiction my
Democratic colleagues want the fix my
Maga colleagues want Fox my Democratic
colleagues want the fix my Maga
colleagues want the fame that's what
this is entirely about and if you have
any questions as to whether that's what
this is about one of the questions
earlier was asking a professor who came
here to talk about immigration in the
Constitution whether she would condemn
hamas's attack on October 7th everyone
here condemns hamas's attack on October
7th but if that same member was asked
would you condemn Donald Trump's role in
the January 6 Insurrection or would you
condemn the people on this committee who
called the January 6 terrorist hostages
an insult to the actual hostages
American hostages in Gaza right now he
would take a pass he wouldn't want to
answer the question they couldn't answer
the question because they won't condemn
it they don't want the fix they want the
fiction if they were not willing to hold
Donald Trump accountable for his
impeachable crimes I don't really want
their hot I don't want their hot tap on
secretary is recognized for five minutes
of
questioning thank you madam chair
um M nobl Miss nun I'm very sorry for uh
your loss losses
um I don't have children I couldn't
imagine what you've you've gone through
um but miss Noble I want to start with
you uh the Department of Homeland
Security and the Department of Health
and Human Services have systems in place
to ensure that unaccompanied Alien
Children from non contiguous countries
are transferred from Customs and Border
Protection to the office of refugee
resettlement o
the house Judiciary report regarding
your daughter's murder notes that o lost
track of more than 85,000 children and
placed fewer than 15,000 follow-up calls
after discharging an additional 32,000
children at no point did anyone from CBP
or HHS flag this violent Criminal Who
had a criminal gang history along with
multiple MS13 tattoos sbles does this
sound like a well-run system meant to
protect American people
no her murderer was apprehended at the
border of March of 2022 they had him
they did not check they didn't check for
his background check they let him go to
an unknown sponsor don't even know who
the sponsor is and she takes him to
Frederick
Maryland from Texas to Maryland and then
he ended up in the same trailer as my
daughter as you said
the is it turns out the murderer was a
known gang member was a 16-year-old
known gang member affiliated with MS-13
in El
Salvador and since the current
administration's open border policy
began we've seen a sharp increase in the
number of known criminals crossing our
Southern border that is included members
of MS-13 whose motto is kill rape and
control my district on Long Island has
suffered from high levels of gang
activity especially MS13 for years um it
stopped actually when uh the former
president increased uh he when he
increased FBI and cooperation and police
protection on Long Island so we had we
we were actually winning the battle for
a while um but unfortunately that's
that's starting to change again and
uh you know just this summer a member of
MS 13 plad guilty to the murder on Long
Island to pled guilty to the murder of
two teenage girls who are attacked with
B baseball bats and
machetes um this is just one of the many
examples
do you
think border security and proper alien
Ving is a national security issue yes
and supposedly he's 16 we don't know his
real age exactly they don't but they're
treating him as a juvenile but well
that's actually that's true one of the
for the UAC is one of the when I went to
the one of the times I went to the
Border because I've been several times
um CBP was saying that when they were
processing people who were trying to be
under trying to show that they're under
18 they actually found real
documentation showing they were between
the ages of 25 and 30 so it's it we
don't know exactly how old is like you
said no
um this committee has been focused on
Biden administration's refusal to secure
our Southwest border and V alien Rivals
a report from the house Judiciary
Committee like I said like I mentioned
before pointed out multiple vetting
failures with your daughter's killer its
report shows that your daughter's murder
was arrested for association with MS13
well before he came to the United States
something that the US officials verified
easily after the murder unfortunately it
was after um and you like you said the
report also noted that the alien was
released after he was arrested for
murder do you think secretary mycus has
done an adequate job vetting illegal
aliens coming across our border no
because if he was vetted he would have
never been allowed in he would have
never been allowed to come here and
commit that horrific crime on my
daughter thank you for your answers and
again I'm very sorry uh for your
um I'm not yelling at you I'm
no it's okay I'm from New York it's
sometimes our tone gets we get I'm not
yelling this is just how I talk that's
well no I was telling you I wasn't
yelling at you no I was just you know um
Miss Dunn quickly the uh the United
States is in a fentel crisis we all know
that um and it's being inflamed by the
open Southwest border alisten our cardic
have resulted in hundreds of thousands
of deaths in just the past few years
fentanyl is highly addictive incredibly
potent and easy to make which is why
it's a favorite drug for the cartels and
Drug traffickers I'm sure you've
answered this already today multiple
times but I think it's worth getting it
on the
record uh multiple times do you believe
that secretary orc's open borders have
exas exasperated exacerbated the fentol
epidemic
yes I believe so do you believe that
secretary mycus is doing enough to fight
The Scourge offense at all not at all no
why not don't I he
he needs to lock down that
border everyone keeps saying give them
more money those poor border patrol
agents are now the welcoming committee
they are ordered to be the welcoming
committee they don't want to be the
welcoming committee they're told to do
that by mayorcas by this Administration
just like the young lady next to you had
said it's either mayorcas or the Biden
Administration somebody is telling the
poor board Patrol to not do their job no
matter how much money you give them
they're still not going to be allowed to
do their job gentleman's time is expired
thank you gentleman from California is
recognized for five minutes of
questioning thank you very much uh thank
you to our Witnesses um want to just get
back to where we're here this is of
course another effort and this hearing
is really about demonizing migrants and
again smearing secretary morcus uh
Professor pearlstein thank you for being
here are there any grounds again for
impeaching secretary mayorcas under the
Constitution
I don't believe the Constitution
supports impeachment in this case thank
you and as far as I'm concerned that's
the most important question and really
gets to the heart of why we're here
today we talked a lot about the fentel
crisis and fentel in this committee and
and today but the fentel crisis we know
is a tragedy but we also think important
to remember who didn't end the fentel
crisis that was actually Donald Trump Mr
chairman I asked unanimous consent to
introduce this article titled sen
synthetic opio overdose deaths sword
while Trump was President I also would
like to into the record put this other
article opioid crisis critics say Trump
fumbled response to another deadly
epidemic and I bring these documents up
because I think it's really important to
note that during Trump's presidency the
federal crisis had already been a huge
challenge across this country in fact
Trump said before the 2016 election he
said the opiate crisis was destroying
lives and shattering families and he
said quote we are going to stop the
inflow of drugs into New Hampshire and
into our country 100% 100% Trump
promised in 2017 Trump's first year in
office more than 42,000 Americans died
from overdosage linked to heroin fentel
and prescription opioids there was a
huge fentanyl problem when Donald Trump
was President the administration didn't
even bother to issue a national strategy
on fentanyl in his first two years in
office so I think it's crazy that the
majority is trying to turn this into a
Public Health crisis that somehow new or
began during the Biden Administration
unfortunately this is about much larger
issues that we have because our
conversation today isn't about the
Constitution or the law it's not even
about securing the border the majority
is not interested in Solutions Donald
Trump as always said the quiet part out
loud when he said immigrants and I quote
are poisoning the blood of our country
as as we know this is this is rhetoric
uh that could be compared to Hitler and
the kind of rhetoric that he used
extremists here in Congress also
continue to push issues like the great
replacement Theory and we should be
clear immigrants are some of the most
patriar IC and hardworking people there
are in this country I just heard a
Committee Member say and I quote um they
are not prepared to be assimilated
talking about immigrants I'm an
immigrant I think I'm pretty well
assimilated here I am a member of
Congress and so I think it's very
unamerican to attack and demonize
migrants um the way that some in this
majority continue to do um immigrants
aren't here to poison or victimize the
American people I also want to just
touch on this issue of crime um some in
the the majority continue to talk about
crime and crime is a horrific tragedy
clearly I I feel horrible for the for
our witnesses that are here that have
lost um members of their family but
let's look at real data as well both
undocumented and documented immigrants
are much less likely to commit crimes or
be incarcerated than native born
American citizens our border communities
are often safer from violent crimes than
many interior cities and according to
FBI crime data crime in Border
communities was measured to actually be
15% lower than the national average so
from a crime perspective more crime is
being committed by American citizens
than those folks that are undocumented
or that are immigrants Democrats also
want an orderly and secure border we
want real solutions to the fental crisis
but we need to understand the problems
we're trying to solve need Solutions
legislation not impeachments of the
secretary and certainly not impeachments
of President Biden uh the idea that any
of these problems will be solved by the
border alone I think is also crazy these
problems have existed for decades we
haven't had immigration reform or any
sort of policy in over 30 years and
without legal Pathways we won't never
have an orderly border that is also a
fact and we can have a conversation with
a pres with a president with a
presidential candidate a former
president who thinks immigrants are
poisoning the blood of our nation who
thinks that we should build a moat with
alligators along the border who thinks
that we should put Spike on the wall
that he's trying to build who has said
that we should shoot migrants in the
legs as they're crossing the border who
thinks we should send missiles into
Northern Mexico these are the ideas
being offered by the N the likely
nominee of the Republican party and by
many on this committee and in the
Republican majority we need to have real
solutions we need we don't need uh
Donald Trump's horrific policies to come
back to this country and we certainly
shouldn't be impeaching secretary Yus
and with that I yield
back I now recognize myself for 5
minutes for months now we have been
hearing the Staggering statistics about
the catastrophe at our Southern border
the millions of migrants coming across
our border illegally the human
trafficking the fentanyl the Lost
unaccompanied miners but today we hear
something that is even more important
than that today we hear the real
personal stories of of unfathomable loss
and irreplaceable lives and yet even in
the face of this testimony that we have
heard today and the testimony that came
before it our colleagues across the
aisle impune the purpose and the
necessity of this hearing calling it a
political sham calling it a stunt
calling it
theater and they suggest that what we
actually need to do is pass more laws so
as a former Federal prosecutor and judge
I'll start today with a refresher on a
few of the things that are currently
illegal in the United States of America
it is illegal to traffic fentel in the
United States of America human
trafficking is illegal in this country
theft is illegal in this country rape
and murder are illegal in this country
what's more the Department of Homeland
Security has an absolute obligation to
detain and remove those who enter this
country illegally we do not need more
laws we need a president of the United
States and a secretary of the Department
of Homeland Security who enforce the
laws of this country but what do we have
instead an Administration that has
deliberately subverted the duly enacted
laws of the United States of America
that have deliberately defied the orders
of courts in this United States of
America who have ordered and directed
that they desist
they desist these unlawful policies we
have a Department of Homeland Security
that has defied inquiries from the
United States Congress and as for the 27
appearances of secretary Alejandro
morcus in front of this congress not one
of those times did he admit that we have
lost operational control of our border
that we have seeded control of our
border to the Mexican drug cartels or
acknowledge the scope scale and crisis
that our communities all across America
face as a consequence as a direct
consequence of these Lawless
policies every single time an individual
is allowed to enter this country
unlawfully Americans are less
safe Miss Nobles Mrs Dunn as a mother
I see my child and my family in those
photos that you shared with us
today and it is truly something that we
cannot fathom the loss that you have
each suffered I thank you for your
willingness to come here today and share
with us your
stories I would like to hear your
perspective please on what more Congress
could be doing to support you and to try
to prevent this type of unspeakable
tragedy from happening in the lives of
another family we'll start with you miss
Nobles I would like to see
every um illegal immigrant who wants to
come here to be properly vetted and
background check I hear a lot about more
funding resources and all that how is
that going to help them do their job in
the first place they failed Kayla by not
checking her murderer background and
didn't not make that one phone call one
one phone call could have saved my
baby's
life they didn't and after he was
arrested they puty um Child Protective
Services took him and put him in an
unsecure children's home with other
children and I know
Americans commit crimes on other
Americans but why do we have to take
other Count's
trash why do we need them
Miss
dun we we talked about a lot today
um about more resources at the border
and and I appreciate that and I respect
that but I don't think that members in
this room and other rooms at the capital
understand that we are actually at War
and we're at war with the
cartels we're we're losing our our
children we're losing a generation of
children we're at War we need our
military at the border that's what we
need we don't need more border patrol we
need our military at the border stopping
the drugs stopping people from coming in
they can't come in we're full we're
closed that's
it no more
money no more no more sandwiches
it's closed I'm sorry come through the
proper challenge channels I am a first
generation American my parents both
migrated here guess what they did it
legally thank you Mrs dun my time has
expired I now recognize the gentleman
from New Jersey for five minutes of
questioning thank you uh and thank you
to the witnesses for for appearing here
today uh I uh I appreciate you sharing
your stories and um and I'm sorry for
your measurable grief um and the folks
on this committee look forward to to
working together in a way where we can
solve some of the challenges that are
facing our country but since this is an
impeachment hearing I will direct my
questions to professor pearlstein as the
professor has observed there are
provisions of the Constitution that are
murking subject to debate and Provisions
that are clear Article 2 Section 4 is
clear treason B bribery and other high
crimes and misdemeanors are the only
constitutionally permissible grounds for
impeachment my Republican colleagues
have not come close to making a
constitutionally sound case for
impeachment against secretary my orcus
they have incorrectly argued the
secretary's designations of certain
groups are El as eligible for parole
constitutes quote Mass parole and is
inconsistent with law each case is
considered on a discretionary Case by
casee basis which is a requirement in
the immigration nationality act it is
worth noting that Parole Authority has
been used by every Administration since
President Eisenhower who paroled 30,000
Hungarian Nationals fleeing communism
Professor pearlstein does the
secretary's exercise of well-established
Parole Authority constitute treason
bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors I don't believe it does no
thank you my Republican colleagues have
also argued that secretary Mor orcus is
violating the law by releasing migrants
awaiting adjudication of their Asylum
claims that claim is not true and that
practice is not new in fact DHS released
hundreds of thousands of individuals at
the US Mexico border under President
Trump professor pearlstein does
detaining migrants in a matter
consistent with the law and the
resources provided by this Congress
constitute treason bribery or other high
crimes and misdemeanors no it doesn't
finally my Republican colleagues have
also incorrectly criticized the
secretary's guidelines for the
enforcement of civil immigration law
which prioritize enforcement actions
based on National Security Public Safety
and border security but as Justice
Kavanaugh observed in United States V
Texas Article 2 of The Constitution
confers upon the ex itive Branch the
quote authority to decide how to
prioritize and how aggressively to
pursue legal actions against defendants
who violate the law and that principle
extends to the immigration context
Professor pearlin do exercising
wellestablished authority to prioritize
immigration enforcement actions
constitute treason bribery or other high
crimes and misdemeanors no sir thank you
this committee has engaged in months of
so-called investigations into the
administration's border security
policies despite all all the time and
resources committee Republicans have
invested they still cannot make a case
for impeaching the secretary that meets
constitutional muster instead of wasting
more time on a baseless impeachment we
should get back to the work of passing
bills that will actually help solve
problems but Republicans don't seem
interested in that they made their
immigration proposal hr2 as cruel and
unworkable as possible rejecting every
Amendment Amendment Democrats on this
committee offered in good faith
amendments some Republicans agreed would
improve the bill everyone on this
committee wants to fight the scourge of
fentanyl in this country that's why
during our markup of hr2 I offered an
amendment to authorize the bid
administration's Operation Blue Lotus an
aggressive strategy for fighting drug
trafficking with a proven record of
stopping Fentanyl from being smuggled
into the country but every one of the
republ of my Republican colleagues voted
against
it why because while they talk the talk
they refuse to walk the walk hr2 you
talk about in every response what's your
alternative to hr2 why is it half to be
hr2 or nothing if you're serious about
figuring out the Border work with us
let's come up with another solution but
you go back to hr2 every time you're
challenged about the substance of what
we're doing here while you are in the
majority On the Border come up with a
second proposal or a third proposal that
can pass this house be signed into law
and we can get to work you sit on hr2
you point to hr2 and say that's the work
we've done meanwhile you bring these
Witnesses here to talk about the
tragedies they've experienced but what
are we doing now what's your proposal
now besides hr2 there's nothing there's
nothing this is this is about scoring
political points you want to make this
Administration look weak On the Border
when are we going to put our country
above party again I believe in you guys
I believe you want to do that let's do
it but talking about hr2 as a solution
is a farce and uh one day I do hope that
we can work together on these issues I
would love to do that because the work
of this country is critical and we need
to get to it with that I yield
back now recognize the gentleman from
New York for five minutes of questioning
I appreciate my colleague from New
Jersey's comments I do believe he's
operating in good faith but I just think
he's wrong um and while there's
squabbles between members of both
parties in this committee the executive
branch has every Power uh in its tool in
its toolbox to get this done right away
it can reinstate remain in Mexico can
stop the repositioning of Border agents
away from the order and towards
microprocessing centers uh it could do
things on its own through executive
action to to claim this mess hr2 is our
response to that that would require the
administration to do those things to
protect Americans um Madam chairwoman we
spent 13 months in this committee laying
out the case that our our border is not
secure and Americans are with us with on
this 67% of Americans um think the
president is failing in his duty to
secure the Border uh much of our case in
the last 13 months has been backed up by
data some pretty big numbers millions of
migrants unlawfully mass paroled into
the United States hundreds of thousands
of Goda ways and tens of thousands of
fentanyl deaths but today it's not about
the data um before us today are two
actual victims of secretary may oris's
open border a mother whose daughter was
sexually assaulted and murdered by an
MS-13 member and another member whose
daughter was fatally poisoned by
fentanyl Miss dunam Miss Nobles um as a
father of three young girls for whom I
would do and give anything I can
literally not imagine what you're going
through I appreciate you being here
today um ripping off some of the scabs
of the wound that has been caused and
telling us your story so that we can be
more informed and uh and help solve this
problem appreciate you being here today
um Madam chairman if we had a more
secure border these horrific tragedies
could have been avoided if secretary
meor has stopped rolling Mass groups of
migrants into United States these
tragedies could have been avoided if
secretary morus stopped repositioning
border agents away from the border just
to sit behind a desk to process more and
more unvetted migrants into the United
States we would have less grieving
mothers Madam chairman the Biden
Administration has often falsely claimed
that 90% of all fentanyl comes through
ports of Entry I actually have a video
of secretary morcus claiming um that and
if we could play that please and people
should understand it is not in between
the ports of Entry uh that the majority
of of fentanyls sought to be smuggled
it's not through the migrants that we
encounter in between the ports of Entry
it's through passenger vehicles through
commercial trucks at our ports of Entry
where the substance is concealed in
compartments Congressman um the US
Customs and Border Protection data um
evidences that more than 90% of the
fentanyl that enters this country is
coming through the ports of
Entry the secretary is wrong and he's
smart enough to know that he's wrong 90%
only accounts for what is seized and not
what actually makes it across the
borders only the cartels probably uh who
are profiting millions tens of millions
a month know how much fentol is actually
making across the borders in fact border
patrol officials have told this
committee they believe that only 5 to
10% of fentol is actually seized the
fact that there are more than 70,000
deaths in our country in 2022 from
fentanyl should be a Telltale sign that
fentol is flooding into this country not
only through ports of Entry but in
between ports of Entry as well miss Dunn
um do you think that pulling border
patrol agents away from the border just
to have them sit behind a desk to
process to mass process more and more
migrants into the country is a wise
decision no do you think that that
decision leads to more opportunity ities
for the cartels to traffic fent andol
into this country
yes thank you and what impact um and I
know you have a the most personal of
experience um but what impact do you
think that fentol has had on the public
health of the United
States well um the most obvious one in
that I can see is I have a grandson that
doesn't have a mother he has other
family that is able to raise him but we
haven't even beg to talk about the
foster care system and how many children
have lost their parents little babies
under 18 that are now Wards of the
states where's all that money coming
from and let's think about the traumas
and sadness and what it's like to not
have parents because their parents died
from
fenel Miss dun the secretary Knows Your
Story um and he knows of other stories
like yours and he hasn't changed his
policies he hasn't insisted those border
agents stay on the border he hasn't
canceled the mass parole of Migrant to
the United States what could you say
with respect to the secretary's likely
approach and his care for situations
like yours given that he hasn't changed
his
policies it's very difficult for me to
contain what I would say how about that
I appreciate that I'd rather I'd rather
not say what I would like to say you're
a classy person and I appreciate you
being here before us today I
yield gentleman yels I now recognize
Miss Clark from New York for her uh five
minutes of questioning thank you Mr
chairman I thank our ranking member uh
good afternoon and thank you to our
Witnesses for appearing here today and
to our bereaved mothers um you have my
deepest condolences
earlier today my colleagues discuss
discussed Republican opposition to
providing CBP much needed resources in
the FY
2023 funding bill but that isn't the
only time Republicans have opposed
resources to secure our border in
October President Biden sent Congress a
supplemental funding request for FY 2024
which included an additional 13 6
billion for border security it would
provide an additional 1,300 border
patrol agents to work alongside the 20
20,200 agents already funded by the
requested FY 2024 budget
375 immigration judges teams to
strengthen the Immigration Court System
1,600 Asylum officers to speed up
processing of Asylum claims 1,000 CBP
officers with a focus on countering
fentol new detection technology for
ports of Entry more immigration
detention beds additional
investigative capabilities to combat
fentanyl trafficking and $600 million
more in Grants to help communities
receiving migrants among other
Investments as secretary mayorcas and
bipartisan members of the Senate are in
negotiations to get these much needed
resources enacted House Republicans are
just
absent instead they are focused on
impeaching secretary
mayoras Professor pearlstein do
impeachment resolutions change
policy no ma'am do they provide
resources or authorized
funding no ma'am even if House
Republicans attempted to impeach
secretary moorus is successful the
Senate would have to convict isn't that
correct yes that's true and how many
senators are required to con convict the
secretary conviction requires two-thirds
of the Senate after a conviction what
happens next uh the person would be
removed from office and the president
has the opportunity to appoint uh
someone new the secretary would be
removed and for a period of time pending
confirmation of a new secretary another
official would serve as acting secretary
is that correct that's correct would
that individual be obligated to execute
the administration's policies yes he
serves at the pleasure of the president
so functionally nothing would change
that's correct If instead House
Republicans decided to negotiate and
pass the president's supplemental
Appropriations what effect would that
have on resources and
policy Congress could pass laws today
that have enormous effect not just on
the availability of resources but how
those resources are allocated so if
Congress is unhappy with for example
where officers are placed um Congress
can impose conditions on existing funds
that require the president to do
something different if they believe that
the president or the secretary is not
complying with those laws they can
challenge them in court and that's
exactly the process that's been playing
out in recent years very well Mr
chairman Republicans have a choice they
can continue to pursue this sham
impeachment of secretary mayorcas which
will change nothing and in fact could
slow down efforts to address challenges
at the Southwest border or they can work
with the White House and bipartisan
members of the Senate on legislation to
improve border security and reduce drug
trafficking I urge my colleagues to get
back to work for the American people and
with that I thank you and I yield back
the gent lady yields I now recognize Mr
strong for his five minutes questioning
thank you Mr chairman um Miss Nobles my
heart goes out to you for the loss of
your daughter uh thank you for being
here with us today and for sharing her
story as you've been told this committee
uh today uh the man that took Kayla's
life was in this country
illegally he was originally from El
Salvador where he was know a known
member of the MS13 gang of which was
later easily verified both by his gang
tattoos and by a simple call to the El
Salvador government Miss Nobles does it
concern you that secretary morcus has
not made any significant changes to his
border policies especially ones that uh
make it easier for illegal aliens to
enter and um continually be released
into our country without proper vetting
yes very concerning because I don't want
this to happen to someone else's
daughter or our child thank you in
August of 2023 there was an individual
arrested in Alabama whose background is
stunningly similar to Kayla's murder he
was an El Salvador illegal here in the
US he was also a member of the MS13 and
on El Salvador's top 100 most wanted
list he earned a spot on this list for
aggravated kidnapping attempted ad
aggravated homicide agravated homicide
aggravated extortion and terrorist
organization he was previously deported
yet my orcus opened the border and was
able to make uh make it uh back into
this country um you start looking at
this Mr Noble this illustrates um what
we both know to be true these are
unfortunately not isolated events as a
matter of fact from fiscal year 2021 to
date border patrol has recorded
41,100 arrests of illegal aliens with
criminal backgrounds approximately 88%
higher than the combined uh previous
physical years um uh the four years
combined Miss nobl shouldn't just one
instance that an illegal alien has
endangered or taken the life of an
innocent American like your daughter be
a wakeup call to secretary my orcus and
President
Biden yes most definitely as a member
just said there are no experts to raise
their hands and say my orcus should be
impeached Miss no uh Miss Nobles and
Miss dun let me get one thing straight
you're
experts you lost it
all as a matter of fact it has been more
than just one instance in Alabama alone
may 2023 an illegal alien from Honduras
raped a teenage girl in a restaurant
bathroom November 2022 an illegal alien
sodomized a 13-year-old boy July 2022 an
illegal immigrant from Mexico killed and
dismembered a woman's body and her child
the Lone Survivor a 12-year-old girl
escaped after watching this horrific
scene and being held captive with the
decomposing remains how many more
stories like this will it take for
secretary morcus and the Administration
to wake up the stay in Mexico act it
worked the stay in Mexico act it worked
I don't care which president was there
whether it was Obama whether it was
Trump the stay in Mexico act worked
process them fuel up ice air send them
back to the country of their origin if
not this then what will compel them to
act I agree secretary my orcus is not
the solution he is part of the problem
he created this
circus he has failed to carry out US law
8.5 million illegals have crossed the
southern border from 160 company uh
countries they've come into our country
they're invading our country from 160
countries fentol crossing the border by
planes mules drones child saavy uh
slavery is rampant and both sides of the
aisle know it 85,000 children illegally
brought into America and this
Administration says we have no clue
where they are no clue where they are
guess what they're in sex slavery in our
country let me answer the fact but I'm
telling you right now both of you are
experts you lost it all you lost your
daughters you're an expert Mr chairman I
yeld back
gentleman yields I now recognize uh the
gentleman from Oklahoma Mr Buren for his
five minutes of testimony or
questioning uh thank you Mr chairman uh
given a markup that's going on in budget
appreciate your indulgences um with me
slipping in
um you know just as as my colleague just
talked about just the great loss thank
you both very much for uh your courage
given what you've been through um when
know that the decisions by my orcus in
addition to justce administration's
decisions have caused Chaos on our
Southern border um just their reluctance
to Simply enforce Congressional law um
whether it's parole um detention
deportation um these are all things that
Congress set up as a barrier to protect
us against the heinous acts that that uh
the mothers in this room have uh your
families have been the victims of I um I
want to ask you um Miss Nobles uh your
in your testimony you said that the El
Salvadorian government had a documented
criminal history of your your daughter's
murderer now we're talking about an
illegal alien um who uh assaulted
sexually assaulted and murdered your
daughter and they were aware of this
involvement and that there was an MS-13
gang membership was also associated with
this individual how long after your
daughter's death were you made aware of
this
we at um at first we did not know that
he it was MS13 until after the DNA um
evidence came back linked him and then
once he was arrested then we were told
it was an MS13 gang member and he has
like 11 charges against him right now
and and what was the Federal agency that
provided that information to you um it
was no federal um it was it it it took
the local detectives to find out that he
was
MS13 and when you were told this and
were you given an explanation why DHS
Department of Homeland Security never
checked um his body U tattoos that would
bring about you know suspicion or
contact the government um to ask if he
had affiliations or a prior criminal
history did you have you had a chance to
ask DHS about that failure no they DHS
and DHHS has failed to make a comment or
say anything to me about Kayla or
anything um let me ask you do you think
Miss Nobles that the secretary is doing
everything he can uh to secure that
southern border no no I know it's a it
comes across as a question that um that
anyone who's lost what you've lost you
have the utmost right to to be hurt by
the American people it's one thing to
abstract talk about this it's another
thing to to be victimized by someone's
refusal to enforce what the law of the
land is what congressional law is um if
you were able to speak to Secretary of
my workers which you know my inclination
is he probably is paying attention even
though he's refusing to come and and be
a part with the invitation that our
chairman sent him what would you say to
secretary my orcus and what questions
would you ask him and I'll give you all
the time you want I'm going to L I'm
going end my conclusions there um when
you get done Miss nobl if there's time
Miss done on the clock up here I'd love
to hear your comments as well would you
tell the secretary I would ask him how
did you allow a known game member to be
allowed in this country how can anyone
be okay with a known gang member to come
into this country and to end up in
Maryland and I also wanted to know what
else DHS and DHHS is
hiding i f um I was told that her
murderous file is so
thick that that Jim Jordan only had two
hours to even look at the file what else
are they hiding about this murderer I
want to
know I mean I'm not you know I want to
know what they're hiding about this
murderer that's why why it why he is
being protected why everything about him
is being
protected we haven't even got to trial
yet her trial is set for June 28th of
this year and they have four or five
thick binders full of a bunch of
evidence that we haven't
even know yet we don't even know over
half of the stuff that was done to her
in that
room me I'm going to ask you as a
followup I got 30 seconds left there's a
statement that talks about um I actually
quoted this to my orchest when he was
before this committee it actually comes
out of of the Old Testament or the Torah
um where it talks about blood on your
hand if you see destruction coming
talking about a Watchman and you don't
cry out do you think the secretary based
upon him knowing what is happening
letting people come into this country do
you think he has blood on his hands yes
he is responsible for my daughter's
death Miss
dun I I know that secretary Marcus has
two
daughters and they're grown adults and
I'm I just don't know how he would feel
if it was one of his daughters that he
lost to either one of these situations
we talked a little bit today about
resources okay I have a resource in my
purse it's Naran it costs $45 in a
pharmacy in Arizona it's not free you
want to spend some money you want to
spend some of my tax dollars give this
away for free everywhere anywhere
everywhere that's what you need to spend
your money on
I don't want to spend any more money on
illegals I want to save
lives thank
you gentleman NE I now recognize a
gentleman from Texas Mr Latrell for five
minutes questioning thank you all for
coming today
I everyone in here sitting I spoke to my
Democratic colleagues and my Republican
colleagues and our our hearts are with
you and and um I hope that doesn't seem
meaningless coming from where we're
sitting today unfortunately you've
you've got to experience what Congress
is all like right here in real life and
normally when you're watching C-SPAN you
can usually turn it off um but this is
this is how we interact with each other
unfortunately but thank you and I'm very
very sorry for for your
loss um I was a military man in my my
former life and when forward deployed
overseas task with securing any given
area we followed that under the
Constitution as military men because we
raised our right hand and swore to
defend the Constitution of the United
States and sometimes our jobs were to
prevent movement through any given space
our job was to protect our men and women
that were tasked underneath us
wholeheartedly
unconditionally and in war you lose men
and women you do it it's just part of
the conflict um there's no great there's
there's nothing you that can be said
that to anybody when that happens um but
it is it's absolute
Warfare but as a military man as an
officer if any given space that I was
defending if it was rushed by
individuals and overtaken I would be
relieved of command plain and simple my
leadership would look down at me it's
like you failed we're going to relieve
you of your duty if I lost
lives and most likely if it was
negligent I would be relieved of Duty
depending on the surge of numbers and
however that played out there there
could possibly have been a court Marshal
and I lived by that we all
do so when I I see these numbers and
this is where I sit why I'm going after
the impeachment is When I Look to the
leader that's supposed to be defending
our country and just numbers I don't
care if Democrat Republican just sheer
numbers yearly since the secretary has
been in position the numbers have grown
exponentially they have numbers of which
if that had happened to us overseas it
have been catastropic because if I if my
leadership didn't take control and act
accordingly the Navy would have and then
it would have grown and grown and grown
until we were held
accountable each year since secretary's
been in place those numbers for fentel
deaths sex trade gang members not to
mention the amount of addiction we talk
about deaths but the addiction rate is
astronomical if those numbers were
dipping down that's one thing but
they're progressively getting worse and
worse they're out of
control Professor my I have a question
for you I know that you don't support
the impeachment of secretary mayorcas
constitutionally do you support the
removal given the sheer numbers that
we're
seeing do you you support the removal or
would you support the removal period of
secretary
moorus because of his failures to lead
the Department of Homeland
Security I'm simply not an expert on
immigration policy no it's a personal
question I really don't have a position
on the removal of secretary my orcus as
a matter of law I don't think the Bas no
this is this is a personal I know I know
you say constitutionally that is not the
case you don't support that I understand
that completely I understand your
perspective and I appreciate it but the
United States is one of the leading
countries in sex trafficking Houston
Texas is the worst city in the country
which is in my district I represent over
700,000 men and women in District 8 in
the great state of Texas and they are
demanding the removal of secretary
Americus demanding it and I'm the voice
in Washington DC to say hey I'm speaking
for my people and this is what they are
demanding so since the administration
President Biden will not remove Mr marus
constitutionally or however he sees it
and I understand your perspective what I
want to hear is do you do you think Mr
mayus needs to be removed because of his
failure in my opinion in his role what I
think you should tell your constituents
in response to their demands is that
they should vote for a different
president well that's that's Amen to
that I'm sure they're on board with that
exact statement but I do every every day
have to sit in front of the mothers and
fathers of them that have lost their
babies and they're never going to get
their babies back and I can tell them to
vote all day long but four years and is
extremely long time to have somebody
failing Us in protecting our borders so
the Republican party is having to act
and act
accordingly and that's why this Impe
process is happening I understand Mr
chairman I yield back gentleman yields I
now recognize a gentleman from Arizona
Mr Mr Crane for five minutes questioning
thank you Mr chairman uh Miss dun Miss
Nobles thank you so much for coming here
today thank you for your
courage Miss Dunn happens to be a
constituent of
mine she once confronted me at a town
hall in Yavapai County and begged me to
do something about this Invasion at our
Southern
border honestly I couldn't blame her one
bit as a father I would have done the
exact same same thing that you did
ma'am Miss D after listening to my
Democratic colleagues today I I think
you probably had a decent idea of what
the problem was before you came up here
but I think it's a lot more in Focus now
is it
not I'm glad you had a chance to
confront the problem today we will
continue to confront the problem but I'm
glad you got a chance to see it for
yourself Miss
pearlstein you said during the audio
recording that the chairman played one
of the criteria for impeachment is
serious offenses against public trust do
you still stand by this comment today
ma'am as I've explained before offenses
against the public trust are instances
in which an official is willfully acting
for his own benefit or the benefit of
his own power or on behalf of a foreign
power thank you how is this border
crisis that has been planned and
executed by secretary my orcus not a
serious offense to public trust miss
pearlstein having read through the
materials I see no evidence that
secretary my orcus has acted on behalf
of his own benefit financially or
politically and I see no evidence that
there is collusion or other cooperation
or acting on do you see do you see
evidence of betrayal of public trust if
you need help find in that ma'am look to
your right there's two mothers in here
that have had their complete lives
destroyed their families
destroyed I'm going to ask Miss dun do
you have has your public trust in
Secretary my orcus and the Department of
Homeland Security been
broken yes sir Miss
Nobles yes do you guys feel betrayed by
secretary my orcus and the Department of
Homeland Security you guys know his job
is Secretary of Homeland security his
job in his title is to protect the
Homeland Homeland Security do you guys
feel betrayed yes I thought
so M
pearlstein are you familiar with article
4 section four of the Constitution often
known as The Invasion
Clause yes I've read the
Constitution that's not what I asked
ma'am I asked if you're familiar with
that article yes thank you I'm going to
read
it the United States shall guarantee to
every state in this Union a republican
form of
government and here's the here's the
point and shall protect each of them
against
Invasion Miss Nobles Miss done do you
think that this Homeland Security
secretary is protecting this these
states against Invasion protecting
Arizona Arizona is not protected against
Invasion Miss pearlstein after having me
read that do you think think that this
secretary is protecting the 50 states
against
Invasion the word invasion in that
Clause is not in reference to migrants
who are not trying to overthrow the
government of the United States oh it's
interesting that you say that
ma'am very interesting that you say that
ma'am Miss pearlin have you ever studied
unconventional
warfare any idea what that term means
I've heard that term used I'm not an
expert in unconventional warfare do you
have any idea what it might mean go
ahead take a about it I would rather
hear your definition okay great do you
think in any wild and
unprecedented strategy in the history of
the world one of our adversaries might
try and send their soldiers to
infiltrate our country using our
wideopen border not putting them in
uniforms and and and having them come
and present themselves in front of our
border patrol agents and and tell our
border patrol agents oh we're just we're
just we're just innocent immigrants we
just want a better life do you think
that's even possible Miss
prolin might anyone ever lie at the
border yes okay so it is possible that
tens of thousands you know that's how
many we're getting a day right ma'am
about 10,000 a day 10 to 15,000 a day
are you aware of that I'm not aware of
any statistics okay well I'll fill you
in then ma'am you're in the homeland
security committee it's about 10 to
15,000 often sometimes 12,000 a day
that's more than a combat Division
coming through our Southern border from
160 countries some of which are
adversarial and I'm going to tell you
right now unconventional warfare has
been used since the beginning of time
these people aren't stupid they're using
access to our
country to bring in individuals who want
to do harm to it I've been in the I've
been in the classified briefs it's a
fact ma'am how many families have to how
many families have to be ruined how many
mothers have to sit next to you before
you you come to understand this is an
invasion of our country and he's in
complete dereliction of Duty of his
constitutional oath to protect and
defend the United States of America and
how many ma'am would it would we need to
have a 100 here today for
you impeachment will not address the
policy problem you describe that's not a
policy problem that is him
completely deric his oath to protect and
defend the Constitution of the United
States I read you The Invasion Clause he
is not doing that ma'am he's in complete
dereliction of doing it in accordance
with the other laws that other committee
members have read to you today and I
think it's sad this shouldn't be a
partisan issue at all and you know it I
yield back gentleman yields I now
recognize Miss Titus the gentle lady
from Nevada for her five minutes of
questioning thank you Mr chairman uh I
to offer my deepest sympathy to the
witnesses for their loss uh
Professor you're the only expert in here
on this topic would you say one more
time for the record if Co the
Constitution covers what Mr Crane called
dereliction of his oath or any of the
things that are being addressed here in
terms of grounds for impeachment I don't
believe the record supports grounds for
impeachment here no and are you in the
mainstream of other constitutional
Scholars who have taken this position
written letters to the post written
letters to our chairman been public
about this impeachment I signed a letter
that was um in addition to another dozen
or more bipartisan set of constitutional
law Scholars who took the same position
and I want to emphasize that was a
bipartisan list of Scholars who are uh
very versed in this topic and who know
it better than any of us sitting up here
so
um it was interesting to me that when I
heard Miss green and her tiate against
you saying we are not talking about the
Constitution she actually had the gall
to say we're not talking about the
Constitution and she's the one who
entered the resolution that we are
considering so if we're not talking
about the Constitution what are we
talking about uh well we're wasting our
breath talking about history talking
about President talking about previous
cases talking about the language of the
Constitution talking about the original
tent of the Constitution because
obviously the people on that side of the
room are not talking about the
Constitution so they are throwing out
200 years of precedent they're ignoring
the interpretation of all these
constitutional Scholars they're
disregarding some of the comments that
have been made by members of their own
party about the Folly of this uh
resolution and this Pursuit so if we're
not talking about the Constitution then
what are we talking about it's a
political stunt it's an attempt to
distract from a do nothing congress
that's done nothing uh and even less
compared to the do nothing congress so
named uh by Truman and uh you know I I
see another quote that I think is
relevant it was by the assistant
Secretary of Labor uh Mr post who they
brought up uh to to uh impeach in 1920
and by the way it's only been done one
time over a hundred years ago but
they've tried it in 1920 and his
response was it was mental dullness at
high tension I believe we've seen a lot
of evidence today of mental dullness at
high tension with raised voices with
misinformation with accusations with
demeaning comments that was mental
dullness at high tension so if we're not
talking about the Constitution we're
just trying to use some constitutional
terms to pretend like stump the
professor we know more than they do uh I
would say that my colleagues across the
aisle are simply just trying to put
lipstick on a pig and I yell
back the have to decide does the
legislation inacted by The People's duly
elected representatives mean
anything or can the secretary just do
whatever he wants in direct
contradiction to the mandatory language
language in federal law with
impunity I argue that he cannot continue
to not follow the law without
consequences this isn't a policy
difference this is a matter of following
the laws written by Congress and thus a
matter of constitutional
significance today's minority witness re
recognized back in 2019 that someone
could be impeached for a breach of trust
James Madison the primary architect of
the Constitution was elected to the
House of Representatives to serve in the
first Congress at that time a bill was
proposed to create a department of
Foreign Affairs now the state department
concerns were raised that if Congress
created such a department it could be
filled by people who abused the public
trust Madison worried about it and I
quote the difficulty of dis placing
those who are Unworthy of the public
trust end quote but he pointed to a
solution for that concern he said on the
house floor and I quote if an unworthy
man be continued in office by an
unworthy president the House of
Representatives can at any time impeach
him and the Senate can remove him
whether the president chooses or not end
quote I don't know about you but I trust
the interpret ation of the father of our
constitution more than the
interpretation of those desperate to
defend the indefensible for political
game the president has chosen to
continue to keep an unworthy man in
office and it is now the duty of the
House of Representatives to impeach
secretary mayus and the Senate to remove
him from Office the minority witness
said we could pass laws to address these
issues but to what
end the secretary has already shown he
will not follow the laws passed by
Congress secretary mayus has
consistently and deliberately violated
duly enacted laws under the immigration
and nationality act that Congress has
put into place to protect Americans and
guard our nation's sovereignty secretary
me Arcus has refused to comply with
court orders regarding those very laws
in good faith additionally secretary
mayorcas has on numerous occasions lied
or misled the United States Congress and
the American people regarding the
existence and scale of the Border crisis
that he
created secretary mayorcas told the
house Judiciary Committee on April 20
2022 that he had operational control of
the Southern border according to the
definition laid out by the secure fence
act by the way that definition was
passed into law by Joe Biden Brock Obama
and Hillary Clinton and of course
secretary am's his own former border
patrol Chief testified
before this Committee in March of last
year that according to the statute DHS
does not have operational control
secretary May orc's pure dishonesty was
on full
display again not a policy
issue to those claiming this impeachment
hearing is against the Constitution and
against the separation of powers I'm
sorry that's
ridiculous President Biden and secretary
mayorcas are the ones who have trampled
on the Constitution and the the
separation of powers By ignoring a
co-equal branch of
government as far as I understand the
Constitution the Constitution I swore no
to at age 17 on the planeet West Point
Congress writes the laws and the
executive branch executes those laws but
that is exactly absolutely not what
secretary morcus has been doing when it
comes to our country's immigration laws
in fact he's been spitting on those laws
and thus the constitution in the the
last three
years impeachment is our final remedy
we're left with no other
choice this is also not a resource issue
Democrats are wrong when they claim that
the reason this border crisis is
happening is because there aren't enough
resources at the border and that
Republicans have refused to fund the
border patrol first of all House
Republicans have voted substantial
increases in funding for CBP above the
president's requested amount in fact
funding the border patrol operations and
related Southwest border requirements
increased 2.2 billion over since
fy2021 additionally House Republicans in
the fy4 homeland security Appropriations
Bill where we fund the government
increase border security funding again
above the president's proposed budget on
top of this hr2 the secure border act
would fund a border patrol force of 22
,000 yet did any Democrat here vote for
that
no it's the definition of
hypocrisy secondly secetary
meccas
actually asked for less money each year
to fund
detention the one thing that is a
deterrent to people coming and making
that
Trek third it won't matter how many
resources we have at the border if the
policies don't
change and follow the laws written by
Congress President Biden's supplemental
package would do nothing to secure the
border between ports of entry and it
would do nothing to stop the flow of
migrants to our border no every scent of
Biden supplemental package would go
directly toward funding Mass Catch and
Release policies that is a
non-starter that's what's created the
crisis in the first place this is
clearly not an issue of funding DHS has
less fund had less funding under the
Trump Administration for border security
yet our border was far more
secure funding Biden's supplemental
package won't fix the crisis at the
border it will fund
it again it's not a funding
problem secretary mayor's complete
disregard for the laws passed by
Congress have had a devastating impact
that's what we learn today everyone
knows the numbers as one Texas Sheriff
has said and I quote it's quite frankly
a tsunami of death that has crashed into
the United States over our Southern
border it's killing Americans wholesale
and it's just an epid epic Slaughter
manufactured by the cartels if you don't
secure the Border it is going to
continue end
quote Slaughter is the right word to
describe what fentanyl is doing to our
country to our young people to many of
our Sons and Daughters what else do you
call a 100,000 overdose deaths in
2021 and a comparison was made earlier
today between incarceration rates of
native citizens and immigrants or
whatever that is it misses the point
that every crime committed by anyone
who's here illegally is a completely
preventable
crime if you shut the border those lives
are
saved to prevent those crimes you need
only enforce the immigration laws on the
books which is exactly what secretary
mayorcas is willfully not
doing this hearing is titled voices for
the victims the heartbreaking reality of
the mayorcas Border crisis Tammy Noble
daughter Kyla Marie Hamilton no longer
has a voice Josephine Dunn's daughter
Ashley Marie Dunn no longer has a voice
that's why we held this hearing today is
our duty to be the voices of those who
can't speak for themselves and to demand
accountability on their behalf and
finally to secretary mayorcas who
couldn't be bothered to show up
today secretary Mar orcus you have one
job follow the laws and secure the
Homeland yet you allow criminal aliens
to walk across our border to spit in the
face of our country's laws and to
exploit vulnerable migrants secretary
may orcus you have one responsibility
follow the law law and secure the
Homeland yet you allow massive amounts
of fenel to flow across the border and
poison tens of thousands of Americans
secretary morcus you have one duty to
follow the law and secure this Homeland
yet you refuse to let our border patrol
do its job and keep criminal aliens from
coming across the border or allow ice to
deport all criminal aliens when
caught you had one job one
responsibility one duty and you have
refused to fulfill it over and over
again you have refused to follow the
laws and to secure our homeland yet you
shrink your
responsibility this is utterly
disgraceful now I'd like to make a few
other
points someone today has made a point I
can't recall if it was a member or the
minority witness that if you remove the
secretary there'll be no change because
they'll just just put another guy in
there like that well I have a duty to
the people of Tennessee and the people
of
America that if we have a lawless
cabinet secretary who refuses to obey
the laws written by Congress and who
refuses court orders to cease and
desist totally disrespecting the two
other equal branches of government in
our constitution I have a duty under the
Constitution to remove
him and it doesn't matter if the devil I
don't know is worse than the devil I do
my duty is to remove him and I will do
my
duty there have been
some I think we'll say disingenuous
comments about our efforts to get Mr
maych is here today we have tried for
months and months to get him to come and
testify on the border issues the only
time he's come is when he's
constitutionally or legally mandated to
present uh the national threats
briefing he came with the director I I
was glad he was here for that he has
not worked with me to be here in fact
today he decided to meet with some
Mexican officials who come from Mexico
instead of being present at this
hearing that ought to tell you where his
priorities
are now some people have suggested of
course that we could pass some more
legislation well again I did say what's
the use if if he's not going to abide by
it but you know what hr2 sits over there
on the other side of the building well
actually it's that
way I'm not directionally challenged
it's that
way amend
it take the parts you don't like out of
it I think that's the process and then
it comes back over here we go to
conference committee and we work it
out you don't just sit and leave it
sitting on a desk and say you you you do
not right in legislation well yeah we
sent it to you and the process is you
amend it in your committee vote on that
amended version in the Senate and send
it back to
conference so don't sit there and say we
haven't done anything that was months
ago and I I have to address the ranking
members suggestion that we would
use these young women as political pwns
to make a political
statement I am offended by
that his his closing remarks could have
been made at a political
rally it's
despicable to suggest that I would use
the two of you as political
stunts I'm trying to show that every
American is unsafe right now with these
ridiculous border polies IES what
happened to you ladies and your
daughters could happen to any
American and the reason they've happened
is because the secretary isn't following
the laws passed by this body both
Republicans and
Democrats and if he were a republican
I'd be saying the exact same thing has
nothing to do with politics for me spent
years prepared to give my life life for
this
country and at times I thought I might
have no what matters to me is that
document that I swore no to defend and
this secretary has spit on it by saying
that co-equal branches of government
don't matter to him I'm sorry he's got
to
go I thank the witnesses for their
valuable testimony and the members for
their questions the members of the
subcommittees
may have some additional questions for
the witnesses and we would ask that the
witnesses respond to those in writing
persuant to committee rule 7D hearing
record would be held open for 10 days
without objection the ranking member is
recognized you know we've talked several
times about the
rules and we can disagree uh we're
Democrats and
Republicans but I I call your attention
to house rules that uh you've referenced
my comments and that that they were
despicable that's against house rules
actually calling you despicable would be
against house rules calling your words
despicable are not I am I can even say
it's dishonest what you said I can't say
you're a liar it's very clear and I've
made that distinction before actually
Gathering down comments made by De a
republican she actually in that case
called the secretary a liar she didn't
say others now even even others have
said that those words are dishonest or
that that's a lie you can say that you
can't say the individual is a liar your
words were despicable well you I didn't
say anything about you personally well
then then I'm clear as long as you
didn't make benett Thompson yeah I would
never say that about about an individual
sitting in this committee but I was very
disappointed with your accusation that I
would use these individuals IAL Mr
chairman uh your disappointment is fine
but one of the the tenants of of who we
are as a democracy is that I have an
opinion and you have an opinion and and
let's respect that and and so as long as
you understand that we don't have to we
can disagree on the words I was just
trying to get
clarification uh about that and since
you say you Wen talking uh about about
me specifically then I'm fine I yield
back gentleman Ys uh the committee
stands
adjourned
spe